so the big news that came out yesterday
which we talked about a little bit was
that donald trump's actions are under
investigation and like clockwork we uh
we can see exactly how the media handled
it nowhere in the report did they say
trump was under criminal investigation
however merrick garland in one interview
said he wasn't ruling out possible
charges for trump basically saying look
if we find something we will charge him
so it's entirely possible
they're fishing
by by investigating trump's actions
they're trying to find something they
can actually get them on but maybe they
can't
of course now a whole bunch of uh media
is saying people are saying audio
what's going on static audio feedback
buzz don't hear anything let's check and
make sure nothing's crossing wires under
the table a look well i don't hear
anything i don't either could uh did you
guys do it did we do a sound check we
did hey yo we're we're chilling here so
uh
we'll check well it'll be like audio we
might have to we might have to turn the
uh thing on and off
favorite color put your favorite color
in chat
how does it sound now does it sound
better
let's see if it sounds better i'm going
to check for cables overlapping it's
really bad that's usually what it is
buzz thanks for the super chat jimmy joe
somebody said it's just tim's mic
we don't have anything on our end
i got the please do not speak thanks for
the super chat
tron
ian please it's better now
is it better is it better now
people are saying good hey there we go
hey how about we uh we start over how's
it going everybody so anyway we got this
story about donald trump right they're
claiming that his actions are under
investigation and what does that really
mean that someone's actions are under
investigation doesn't mean he is but of
course as we expected many left news
outlets started saying trump is under
investigation because surely that's what
that means no it doesn't that's the game
they're playing at the same time merrick
garland was asked if he would bring
about charges to donald trump and he
didn't rule it out he says you know
we're going to pursue justice equally or
whatever so what does it really mean it
may be one big media hoax trying to
claim that trump will be investigated or
will be charged because they're trying
to rile up democrats to vote in november
i don't know if i believe it so we'll
talk about that we've also got some
other really funny stories trump is
threatening to sue cnn saying he's going
to do it
and then the view has apologized to
turning point usa although many people
are saying that it is
inadequate and i listen to their apology
and i also think it's fairly inadequate
because they really really defamed tpusa
who is now threatening to sue the view
which is probably why they issued their
apology so we will be talking all about
that before we get started my friends
head over to strongerbonesandlife.com
and pick up your ageless multi-collagen
51 off today
as you may notice i've been doing a lot
to be healthy i was cutting out the
sugars i've been having i've been adding
more collagen to my diet because i've
been skating a lot getting injured a
little bit here but that's fairly normal
and i've also admittedly lost a ton of
weight that's the keto stuff the
collagen stuff just keeps your skin your
bones your joints stronger so head over
to stronger bones in life.com and you
will get a 60-day money-back guarantee
the biotrust ageless multi-collagen
provides you the healthy healthy aging
support of collagen and its ideal forms
five key types of collagen you need from
four different sources hydrolyzed
collagen peptides meaning better and
faster digestibility to support maximum
benefits and for every order today they
will donate a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor through their
partnership with no kid hungry.org to
date biotrust has provided over 5
million meals to hungry kids please help
biotrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year
it's non-gmo and free of artificial
flavors colors preservatives and
sweeteners free of gluten antibiotics
nearly no odor or taste there's no
clumping unlike other supplements you'll
get free shipping with every order free
vip live health and fitness coaching
from biotrust team of expert nutrition
and health coaches for life with every
order and their free report 14 foods for
amazing skin stronger bones in life.com
and don't forget to head over to
timcast.com become a member check out
our new shows tales from the inverted
world is up new episodes sundays at 10
a.m hour-long essays
shane cashman investigating the lost
confederate gold down in georgia the
history of the area ufos which is really
crazy stuff and really interesting
stories and i'm hearing the next episode
coming up this weekend is the best one
of the season which you probably
shouldn't say because there's more after
that but it's gonna be good and we're
gonna have a members only uncensored
show coming up tonight at 11 p.m check
it out without further ado we are being
joined by ned ryan
good to be with you yeah now this is
fantastic
who are you
a lot of friends that have been on it's
great to be here uh founder and ceo of
american majority we do political
training state and local uh
the goal being we've got to build a farm
team at the state and local level that's
how you bring about national
generational change kind of reverse
engineering what the progressives did
100 years ago started a state and local
reform movement built from the ground up
obviously radically changed this country
put us in the wrong direction um i'm a
big believer that politics is policy
that unless you win politically all
you're doing is having great
conversations about policy you have to
have political power to actually
implement your ideas i think we got to
change culture
yeah no that's actually absolutely part
of it i think that's more of a long-term
play i think the short-term play people
do ask me how we're going to get back to
normal
we we get political power and we beat
the left into unconditional surrender
and but you have to be you have to be
focused on actually doing that in a
systematic way of identifying training
getting people into office having the
right ideas implemented
telling everyone to go and vote for get
three of their friends to go out and
vote in november yeah get out and vote
voter registration we train people on on
some of that there's a lot of different
things that i think are required and and
been been involved in the movement for a
while and it's been one of those things
that the the conservative movement has
to be more oriented towards action
um i feel like we get stuck in our ideas
and we we like to write white papers and
talk about all these fantastic ideas but
it's it's it's towards action action's
the soul of revolution sounds good man
this should be interesting plus they got
538's claiming democrats are actually
favored to win now
but we'll see that's insane i know i'm
so i know you want to we'll get into it
we'll get into it
lauren southern's back with my thousand
dollar whiskey pleasure to be here paper
cup absolutely i'm just i i make movies
and i'm here to drink papi that's about
it she's intentionally putting thousand
dollar whiskey in a paper cup because
she knows all the whiskey fans are going
to get triggered that was disgusting
that was a club four too by the way like
maybe
yeah
wow
uh lauren uh for those who don't know
who you make movies and you drink
whiskey yeah i'm a documentary filmmaker
do a little bit of [ __ ] posting on the
internet here and there but mostly yeah
just movies youtube videos cultural
commentary all that oh am i not allowed
to swear have i already i mean you can
we just try not to because
you just smash the glass ceiling
rolling i get one i get one pass right
right yeah i want someone cares
nobody cares all right we got ian
chillin hi everyone i did put some
collagen in my coffee i absolutely love
this that's the keto stuff i put the c8
mct and a little bit of collagen this is
not an ad it's just delicious it really
does do it fall medium crosses.net but
let's talk more about i want to talk to
you ned about the political action about
because you're actually inspiring people
to run for office yeah this is badass
yeah no it's and you gotta equip them to
to be successful to win it's all about
winning yeah which we've kind of lost
sight of agreed love it
and i'm also here in the corner i'm very
excited to talk to ned he's very
knowledgeable in history and lauren is
always a blast as well let's get into it
here's the big story from cnn merrick
garland does not rule out charging trump
and others in january 6th probe and i'm
just going to say it i want to bury the
lead i think the story is a big hoax i
think it's a big nothing burger and how
do you say nothing
while still riling up democrats this is
exactly how you do it you go to someone
when there's no criminal investigation
and no charges and say would you charge
him if you found a crime well we're not
going to rule out anything there's no
there's no look let me show you the
story from washington post
justice department investigating trump's
actions
in january 6 criminal probe and we
addressed it a little bit last night but
i'm like i'm seeing all this news pop up
i gotta just say it right now let me put
it this way
lauren southern is drinking my very
expensive whiskey let's say we did not
know who was doing it and so i decide i
know ian doesn't drink it but i'm going
to investigate what he was doing this
night not that i'm accusing him of
stealing my whiskey but something he did
may lead me to information about what
happened to my whiskey this is how i
know
in my is why i would say in my opinion
this story from the washington post is
total bs
investigating trump's actions you can't
criminally charge someone's actions
it may be that they're fishing
it may be there someone else under
criminal investigation and they're
looking at what trump said to him to see
if this person committed a crime but if
i'll just tell you right now if trump
really was under criminal investigation
they would be screaming it to the high
heavens right what but can we get down
to the bottom of what this is all about
it's they're terrified of him the
january 6 committee hearings this
ridiculousness
they're terrified of them running again
they do view him as an existential
threat to the system to the
administrative state that's what this is
what all of this is about it has nothing
to do with anything because there is no
validity to it he said he was going to
fire everybody but exactly
how do you actually get trump to not run
again in 2024 and ostracize his
political supporters from the body
politic that's what they're trying to do
and i think it's great he's he's taking
it head on i mean he came back to dc the
other day and spoke in dc and people
called it controversial
i have no idea like why is it
controversial that a former president
came and spoke in dc oh because of
january 6 the show trial
which has nothing to do with anything
about the facts that happened on january
6th the big story was that he uh called
for the death penalty for drug dealers
ooh like duterte very cool
he was like china doesn't have a drug
problem i think the january 6 committee
hearings have actually helped him
on the path to running again for
re-election have actually strengthened
him i agree and i'll tell you in a
re-election bid and i i i agree with you
and i think it's because the the the
show trial has been so absurd yeah that
it's actually weakened their case
against trump i think the less people
knew about it many of them were probably
like wow something bad happened then you
get this show trial and there's many
inconsistencies and like when jesse
hutchinson oh i know does all hearsay
donald trump jumped and grabbed some
guy's neck people are probably like what
listen listen megatz you just don't
understand we're going to get him this
time now the wall this time we're going
to get him 1000th time and this time
it's going to happen
sorry disappointment it's not i wonder
if there are actually people out there
though like democrats that are just
sitting there watching the view every
day watching rachel maddow that are like
oh my gosh every time they get right up
and they're still falling for it like i
think there's two those people are
excited yes they have to be out there
yeah 25 30
i think actually embarrassing it is
embarrassing really embarrassing but i
think a lot of the normies are looking
at this like you said to him and going
there's no they're there you're bringing
in cassidy hutchinson all these people
it's it's hearsay and then they bring in
pat cipoloni who basically undermines
the secret service agents undermine it's
the more they they more that they're
actually advertising and broadcast and
bring in the abc producer to
show time
people are going there's what are what
are we talking about right here there's
no opposing uh that they can't get to
there's no cross
examination only paul this year uh
amazing meme of chris pratt
the top one is chris pratt with a
shocked happy face saying the first time
a democrat hears the mainstream media
say they have information that will
totally bring down trump right and then
underneath it it says the 4 689th time a
democrat hears the msm say they have
information that will totally bring down
trump and it's the same happy face no
matter how many times they claim it
i remember when uh you know it was like
march of 2021 and these like deep
conspiracy people were like trump's
gonna get reinstated as president it's
coming and i'm just like me and every
other same person was like guys that's
never going to happen it's kind of like
when people watch the same movie over
and over again or listen to the same
song and you they they like it more
as they hear it more
like the 30th time you hear a song it's
like oh now it's even more part of my
soul so like is that what's happening
with the media telling them trump is bad
is it like getting more they actually
like it even more the next time they
hear it
i think they're hopped all hopped up on
hopium and there's no coming down
they're desperate for it to be true they
are absolutely desperate for it what
would it accomplish if it were true what
would it accomplish for instance
positively for the country and for
people what do you think would happen
absolutely nothing no i mean it would
only it would only accelerate the rapid
separation in parts of our society and
culture
if you were to weaponize this is the
other thing too that i love that trump's
standing up to this
somebody's actually standing up to the
weaponization of the law yeah which is
trump
which if we're not very careful that's
how that's how republics which
technically we still are end when you
weaponize the law against political
opponents that's exactly what democrats
are trying to do here see that's the
problem they're weaponizing it against
opponents we just need to weaponize it
against all politicians
i don't disagree at all i'm an equal
opportunist yeah there's plenty of
people all
like i don't know trading stocks with
your insider information like let's just
but you're just talking about
accountability for accountability these
people who never face it ever yes yeah
yeah never once
at some point i mean at some point equal
application of the law is foundational
to our constitutional republic we have a
bifurcated system in which we are now
weaponizing the law against political
opponents
because reasons and that's what it's
because reasons this is what the media
does take a look at this from the
independent donald trump being
investigated by doj in january 6
criminal probe report says no it doesn't
say that at all this is how they launder
the information there's no story the
washington post has no story the the
story is investigators asked some people
about what trump was doing or something
like that and it's like okay does that
mean trump is being investigated
criminally no it doesn't he maybe he
will be you know there's a possibility
that
they're trying to tread lightly and
going after him to not you know shock
the system and cause riots if they came
out and just announced they were doing
it people might get mad so maybe they're
trying to slow roll it i think the
reality is they got nothing and so
they're trying to make it seem like
something is happening and that's why
they put the story out yeah well they
need a story i was just reading a daily
beast article the other day that said
the pope has come to apologize for mass
graves in canada um of course there's no
mass graves and the pope didn't come
with those intentions but if you scroll
down and you click the hyperlinks in the
article that's referencing it all links
to other daily beast articles that are
completely irrelevant to the article
itself and it's like
the way they source this stuff the way
that they write these articles just
desperation for something to latch on to
that's
you know hyper exaggerated for the
audience it's it's tearing our
civilization apart
it's tearing us apart corporate
propagandists are refused to call them
mainstream media
corporate propagandists who are not
there to actually get to the truth of
something but to amplify the message
the narrative of the system
yeah i think for a lot of these people
it's emergent you know some people
believe that at these news organizations
there is a you know hierarchy of a cabal
telling them you must claim trump did
this or that in reality it's just people
trying to maximize what is was
acceptable within their sphere to get
more clicks so what happens is the
washington post publishes a story
exclusive trump's actions being
investigated means nothing someone at
the independent is like
i want to get clicks uh trump's being
investigated because i've heard people
say that to me they said tim this means
trump is being investigated i'm like no
it doesn't in fact even maggie haberman
new york times wrote this does not mean
trump is under investigation but they
they try and do it
this is how
these these you know facebook moms
and msnbc moms and dads get their minds
warped
that their so this independent story is
going to get laundered again and you're
going to get some pundit on msnbc saying
and and now the doj is investigating
trump in a criminal probe i mean this
guy's going down the walls are closing
in yeah they're gonna believe it and
reference the independent and everything
because they all just yeah they
reference each other's opinion pieces
eternally until it's an echo chamber
amplified the message no it it is but i
i think you're on to some obviously they
feed off each other at the same time
they all come from
i call them indoctrination centers of
higher learning they've all come out of
the same system so they all think the
same way they all view the world same
way and they just end up in different
parts and they amplify each other but
they're all coming from the same
cult world trilateral i don't know who's
doing what's this liberal international
economy is like it's there's the liberal
international economy the us britain
australia and then there's the chinese
international economy which is like
china russia india and the thing about
it is like yeah there's like they've
mobilized the media abc cnn to work for
the liberal international economy but i
think if trump was president and was
nationalizing industry that it would
actually be very good for the liberal
international i don't understand why
it's like a personal vendetta between
him and hillary clinton when he's like
you should be in jail he started the
whole weaponizing
politics like he threatened to put her
in jail on his campaign against her they
they
i've talked about it ad nauseum with the
cutter turkey pipeline donald trump
getting our troops out of the middle
east him saying i don't care about these
oil pipelines that was bad for the
liberal international economy they want
a new world they want a new world
economy they do want a new world order
they've said it many times and i maybe
trump's just not they think he's not the
guy to trust them
trump doesn't want that well there's got
to be some sort of world order otherwise
it's world chaos it's the boomer world
order okay how old is hillary clinton
does anyone know she's like seven seven
okay do you know what the average age of
our politicians or uh prime um prime
ministers
presidents in the us was
for the past like since the dawn of time
it's usually been around 50. it's only
been the last few presidents that have
been like 70s 80s like getting up there
and it's because the boomers just will
not let go
they won't let go of the industries they
won't let go of the political positions
and then you've got a lot of young
people millennials gen x all these
younger generations that see no upward
mobility in anywhere in politics no
ability to influence the system
and the boomers will never give it to
them so like as much as i like trump as
a politician it's just you know
it's all of this same generation
refusing to let go of civilization and
then every other generation has become
apathetic i will i will say though i
will say though um
the boomers aren't all bad no there are
some bad courses and they they've
latched on to power
what i think the problem is that
millennials are probably going to be
worse now i know i can hear the gen xers
already screaming saying you're cutting
us out and i'm like no no it's because
actually gen x's i don't think are all
that bad they're not the ones who are
squeezing the reins of power and
corrupting the system there these are
you know people who are coming in and
you know doing a moderately good job and
millennials are nuts so when the boomers
finally relinquish power and it floods
down to gen x and millennials those
insane millennials are gonna just really
screw things up you gotta they're
setting an example these these gen
whatever they are the old people in
power right now that to the millennials
if they do get empowered they're gonna
want to be there for 50 years because
like that's what happened before but
they should be in and out people should
be in and out yeah this was never
intended what we have today it was never
intended to be 40 50 years in the senate
whatever it is you know it it was meant
to be much i mean the average term for a
congressman i think was what two
until turn of the century turn of the
20th century i mean there were a lot of
things that have changed dramatically
over the last hundred years you were
never meant to be there for as long as
they're out they've been yeah but no i a
little bit on lauren
i totally agree
it's time for new leadership we've got
great leadership coming up
ron desantis yes josh holly
i'm hoping jd vance blake masters
you're going to see a lot of 30 and
40-somethings who are going to be
leaders in the senate
you know my my perfect world is trump
2024 and ron desantis you know 20 28 20
32. santa's 24 what do you think
i i actually love that idea if they
could work it out i think trump would
have to go have his uh in new jersey and
and desantis out of florida but yeah
i've heard i've you know i've heard that
but i don't i i read that wasn't true
that really the president the vice
president yeah that's a relic of the
1800s okay but that could be regardless
i think it'd be a great ticket trump is
in new jersey right now right i think it
would be a great ticket residency and i
think if you had trump desantis you set
him up perfectly for a run in 2020 he'd
only be
49 something like that yeah we need to
make room for these new people there's
some really good new yeah i mean i
totally agree i want i want one last run
with trump
yeah i'd like to see and i want him to
announce before the midterms by the way
i wrote a piece on that today why do you
think he should announce before cause i
think he's an asset everybody wants to
say he's not an asset i think he's an
asset he reminds people of what was not
what is oh yeah what did we have we had
1.7 inflation we had 3.5 percent
unemployment two dollar gas two dollar
gas we had a booming economy domestic
energy net exporter
at all these great things about the auto
industry
manufacturing jobs all of these great
things he was taking it to china he was
he was emphasizing even though he wasn't
as successful in the southern border as
he could have been he was still getting
there
he can remind people of what was hey you
want this back get all these people in
and we can get us back on the course of
taking back the country in 2024. i think
he announces tuesday after labor day you
know when he talked about building a
wall and instead of he phrased it as
like we got to keep out and then the
media was like mexicans like you didn't
but
what he kind of meant was like the
cartels and child trafficking human but
he didn't emphasize that enough but did
you see the really funny article today
about in the la times about mexico city
that are deeply resentful of all the
californians in americans yes we don't
want them here they're changing our
culture we want them to go home
yes you didn't see this
it was amazing
i'm like i tell you what i'll make a
deal with you mexico we'll take back all
the americans you take back all the
mexicans we're good now you see what
it's like yeah no it was it was actually
quite hilarious when they
admitted we we don't like having them
here because they're changing our
culture they're changing everything
about this city mexico city
we don't want them here yeah but no i i
i mean yeah i think trump could have
been especially on the cartels could
have been a little bit more precise but
again i mean you deal with the issue of
illegal immigration let's let's pull
this story out here we got from the la
times
in um i don't know what would you call
this irony a total irony l.a times
writes californians and other americans
are flooding mexico city some locals
want them to go home many such cases
amazing sure fernando busta uh bustos
gorozpi was sitting with friends in a
cafe when he realized that once again
they were outnumbered we're the only
brown people said bustos a 38 year old
writer we're the only people speaking
spanish except the waiters it's the
great replacement yeah it's a great
replacement that's what i thought was
the funniest like we're the only people
speaking spanish here we feel cut out of
our own huh the influx which accelerated
medicine
well but it's not mexico it's people
coming from guatemala honduras they're
coming from south america they're coming
from africa i totally agree i mean it's
more than just
mexicans coming across the southern
border but this highlights the point oh
so you don't like it okay
most are against people coming to
america too like mexicans they they
typically are really against illegal
immigration yeah they were they were
really angry that the central americans
were coming no mexico right so what
we're really seeing is that
what i think you'll see from this is
that people who love their countries who
work hard and support their nation
regardless of their cultural background
their ethnic background don't like it
when other people come to where they are
and disrupt their way of life
and americans were doing this because of
coven people were leaving the united
states because of the lockdowns and the
restrictions and mexico was freer yeah
and so now they're like they're coming
here they're bringing their problems
with them it's it's i don't i don't i
see it as ironic
in that it's the americans leaving i see
it as perfectly
predictable that citizens of mexico city
would be upset that other people from a
different country are coming into their
country and changing their way of life
nationalism isn't a bad thing
yeah i think one of the most important
things even if you're talking about
globalism you need to have sovereign
national borders yes because people need
to be able to set their own laws based
on their cultures and their ways of life
if if there are if there are people who
uh there are people who want a one-world
government right it will never happen if
borders are dissolved because people
will be fighting with each other
endlessly it's the same as in
nationalism you need statehood because
you can't have a national police force
on every street corner you got to have
local laws just like in a global force
in the national level people who
understand the local community problems
how to solve them you can't solve them
from a shocking concept yeah but i mean
like even thinking about this is kind of
funny you know we don't have uh borders
between states in the way the countries
do and so what happens when someone from
michigan looking for work goes to new
york people keep flooding to the cities
because cities have jobs and their their
areas don't that hurts everyone involved
so if if you had actually borders which
were more difficult to cross over when
michigan's economy started breaking
because the auto industry was leaving
you wouldn't have the mass exodus which
means the economy may have gotten hurt
but could have recovered much more
quickly with more people requiring
services and working for each other
instead families left in insane numbers
and then the economy just buckles and
collapses because there's no one left to
support the mission
to support the state so this idea of
like multinationalism i guess it'd be
like multi-statism
i don't know like multinationalism would
be like when a corporation has their
headquarters in the united states but
all their production or that bunch of
production is overseas out of the united
states so like
maybe you live in in michigan but you
work in minnesota or something like that
it's legal and it's totally fine and
acceptable but when you see
multinationals i'm like that's pretty
destructive they don't have any
allegiance to the united states even
though they're raking in all the
benefits of tax laws
this has always been one this was one of
my frustrations with the 2017 tax bill
that i thought it favored the
corporations too much over the small
businesses because these corporations
were not america first they have no
inherent loyalty to this country exactly
they're trying to get the best tax rate
they can get and take advantage of the
tax system but there's no inherent
loyalty and we should have we
i made this complaint to the white house
we should have had more
favorable terms for the small businesses
because
half the half the workforce is small
business what do you think about the
idea of like a global minimum tax for
corporations
like there's international treaties
where it's like we the idea i guess is
that a company in the united states will
be like we're going to move our
headquarters to this country all right
to get a tax break right
so the idea is yeah if all these
countries come agree to a treaty it'll
stop the corporations from moving it'll
stop for moving and getting yeah it's i
don't know if i've given a ton of
thought to it i don't think i'm opposed
to it in principle but i think you know
yeah right i haven't given enough
thought to it i'm someone's going to
point out in the chat like here's a
ridiculous problem that will arise from
there probably but there is an issue
that um
you know corporations move their
headquarters wherever they can to save
their tax money so they're basically
ripping us off yeah well that was not
that i'm a big fan of taxes across the
board to be honest no of course yeah no
um i think that's something that we
could have a conversation about across
the board of including property taxes
which i find deeply offensive
let's let's read some more of the sally
time story because i do think it's kind
of funny they say at lardo a
mediterranean restaurant where on any
given night three quarters of the tables
are filled with foreigners a mexican man
in a well-cut suit recently took a seat
at the bar gazed at the english language
menu before him and he sighed as he
handed it back a menu in spanish please
huh
this is just
it's it's how is this real life
i don't know if the li times
i'm not sure they fully comprehended
what they were writing yeah i vibe with
this so hard i grew up in surrey bc if
anyone knows like the area that i grew
up in is like 70 immigrant now
it's pretty wild and you go to some
places and it's like i literally can't
order food here because no one speaks
english it's just like but if i say that
i'm a racist if la times writes about
someone who's brown having the exact
same experience as me because we're all
human and we all enjoy being able to
speak with other humans around us and
being able to read our menu suddenly
it's not racist when someone else has
the exact same internal experience go to
wild go to any country and i assure you
if say you're in turkey
and you hear someone speaking a north
america you hear them speaking english
it doesn't matter what their accent or
dialect is they're speaking english
i assure you you're going to see someone
else be like hey you speak english where
are you from right i was i was in turkey
and i was in there this tower on i think
it's on the great horn or whatever it's
called it's like an old watch tower and
it's a tourist attraction i went up
there and everyone's speaking foreign
languages and then i hear two people
speaking with a north american dialect
and then i was like hey are you
americans and they're like no canadians
and i was like good enough what's going
on what are you doing like hey someone i
can talk to and then right we talked and
it was fun that was it yeah end of story
it was like hey you know i can what are
you doing here you know it was
it's wild it's wild to me that you know
like the left always talk about getting
mad about the great replacement in like
a racial context right but it's like you
guys don't even acknowledge how
damaging it is to have so many people
come in who just don't speak the same
language like language is the only way
we can connect as human beings do
business educate each other
love each other common values
you guys won't even acknowledge the
importance of that imagine you went to
criminal court
charged the crime
and no one's and no one was speaking
everyone's speaking a different language
and struggling to communicate that's
what happened to amanda knox that's she
was actually released from italian
prison but her thing was that they
didn't under it was like the language
barrier was so harsh that they just
threw the book at her and was like she's
a foreigner they're doing it now with
brittany griner so apparently the story
was she doesn't speak russian and her
lawyer was barely translating what was
going on and she had no idea what was
happening so they she kept man knocks
kept repeating herself saying the same
thing because that's all she knew how to
say and the the italians took that as
she's definitely guilty um
you know yeah
yeah dangerous language barrier i'm a
huge advocate of bringing it doesn't
have to be english but a common language
to earth i i'm surprised it hasn't
happened i think the internet sorry we
messed that up all already in 2003 tower
of battle yeah
we have that opportunity to have like a
couple thousand
they put it all in one place so when
that the bat the tower got blown up it
was lost but like if it was diaspora and
like everywhere you know stored in orbit
underground in everyone's bedroom like
everyone's got their data
maybe there's some value to it but the
problem is if you lose other language
because other language gives you
reference that you don't get in english
like certain the word like groomer like
it has an english definition but when
you when you talk about what that means
like groom a dog in other languages it
takes on other connotations and you need
that out external reference to get a
fuller picture yeah so they're obviously
anyone who's ever tried to teach someone
another language knows we say things
that seemingly make no sense idioms yeah
what's up
like
what does that even mean you're asking
you're asking someone what are you
currently doing and what's happening in
your life right that's like oh it's such
a
sup
so if someone is trying to learn english
and you you tell them what's up they'll
look at the ceiling look at the lights
they don't understand that context in in
cultural language so it's like you got
to learn that stuff too
there's there's so much in in language
that people don't understand is rel
relevant uh uh or requires personal
experience of the thing yeah especially
feelings
you know there there are many languages
that have words for feelings that are
really hard to explain to an english
speaker because they've not experienced
it without that you know understanding
yeah it's weird and we've simplified a
lot of things like obviously the word
love we that's just love we just use it
for everything sexual love familial love
we just throw it in one word but then
you have the greek um greek version
which has like you know 12 or something
yeah
is self-love there's agape yeah love of
the community yeah
philadelphia if you get that love is
love statement that ridiculous statement
in the in the pedophile or whatever
community the map the the minor
attractive person community and it's
like no erotic love eros is a specific
kind of love it's not familial did you
just call it the minor attracted
community yeah i hate that yeah
i just noticed there's the um there's
the medical uh psychedelic practices the
maps thing and then there's the map
minor attractive person have you seen
that map is like the uh the maps is like
a psychedelic uh studies program i'm
gonna pull it up well let's i've missed
anyway sorry i haven't missed it all
right ridiculous relationship let's talk
about this uh the story we have here
from the national review
trump says he intends to sue cnn for
defamation
now how much is this just trump blown
smoke or is he really going to do it
it's impossible to sue people it is this
is it really did you see i don't get it
was it clarence thomas
did he say that there's a potential case
coming in front of the court that will
change and actually loosen the standards
by which you can actually do these sorts
of things i think that would be a very
healthy step in the right direction so
here's what trump said he said i have
notified notified cnn of my intent to
file a lawsuit over their repeated
defamatory statements against me
i will also be commencing actions
against other media outlets who have
defamed me and defrauded the public
regarding the overwhelming evidence of
fraud throughout the 2020 election i
will never stop fighting for the truth
and for the future of our country now
that'll be interesting and i don't think
trump will will get anywhere with with
suing them over fraud stuff first and
foremost i think trump thoroughly
misunderstands a lot of uh the 2020
election stuff i think what we saw with
sydney powell and lynn wood
really exemplifies that trump was given
a lot of bad info
i think he's wrong in that regard he was
but i think he could have focused on a
good friend molly hemingway wrote a book
rigged i think there are definitely
serious questions about 2020 but i think
you were right
i mean sydney altman all these and
that's the kraken
right right right right crazy stuff that
threw everything into chaos and i have
to wonder if those people were
intentionally working against trump i
feel like
well because i'll tell you you know i i
want to talk about the lawsuits of the
media so i don't want to get in but i
will mention you know phil uh
pennsylvania changing the rules on
voting was ruled unconstitutional after
the fact but did you see what wisconsin
state supreme court just said recently
they said that the
unsecured ballot drop boxes were illegal
oh right right right you might have
called into questions
there's a lot of stuff that's weird this
is this is the problem with trump and
the fraud narrative is that it's
procedural it's procedural questions on
policy and law that need to be rectified
and don't if that keeps becoming the
narrative because
it's it's it's universal mail-in voting
rules the question the question of the
constitutionality of universal valiant
mail-in voting right election month
versus election day
unmanned drop boxes so
i don't want to get into it yeah we
don't want to go down there i want to
talk about this media lying about
january 6 and all of that stuff
certainly trump has his opinion on all
those things
i gotta say though
if he's suing on those grounds dismissed
instantly yeah because for one the
courts are going to be entirely biased
against hearing any of this stuff but if
he's talking about january 6 then i
think he might actually yeah he might
actually win like what we're seeing now
with the media saying i'm not saying win
in every single instance i know lauren
gave a look of doubt i don't think
people win especially when you're a
public figure like trump even starting
these defamation lawsuits i mean he'd
have the money to do it i guess we'd be
able to start but it's so difficult to
win a defamation lawsuit especially when
you're
when you have other media writing the
same thing about you any media company
will use that as an offense they'll say
everyone else is writing the same thing
so we just wrote it maybe it's not even
about that i mean maybe it's just about
bringing this to the forefront again to
have a conversation about all of these
things here's what will happen one news
outlet let's call it news outlet a will
write something false about lorne
news outlet b will pick it up right news
outlet c will pick it up news outlet a
will retract and apologize and now you
have two outs citing each other and if
you sue one of those they'll say it's
reported as fact by news outlet c you
sue then they'll say it's reported as
fact by news outlet b
and then even if it is wrong they'll say
all we are doing is conveying what
another news already said which we
believe to be true there's no malice and
we're allowed to say it and no one ever
sees the correction it's always
published on a different page months
later and but it still counts it's still
good enough you don't have to that's
what's crazy to me is there's like no
legal recourse for if an article about
you goes completely viral there's no
expectation that the apology afterwards
that will prevent any sort of legal
you know financial scooping will be as
viral and there's no yeah no expectation
one person could see the correction and
that's still okay we're not legally
culpable now that's nuts nuts
there's pros and there's cons um the
idea is that it's it's difficult to sue
anyone in the public space but the
problem then is
they just the media the corporate press
lies about basically everything so i was
thinking about this earlier in order to
sue you need standing and injury which
is insane
how do you prove injury are you going to
go find the guy who wrote you the donor
check who canceled it and then have him
testify that he was gonna he i wrote the
donor check and as soon as i saw that
definition i tore it up so proving that
is insane i think we should be allowed
to sue
for correction
that's it
for correction so you go to a court you
say i can definitively prove the spirit
of what they're saying their statements
are untrue
and then maybe they got to pay legal
fees if they lose for publishing
something false and that's fair
and then it's like then they got to
issue an apology a statement they got to
publish on the front page and leave it
up there for like a week or something
for everyone to see
it's remarkable to me
that you can have a major press a major
news organization lie
and so i've been through this i've
talked to lawyers and they're like what
are your damages and then i was like
well obviously they're trying to get me
banned shadow band reduce wages and
things like that or income and like can
you prove it it's like unless unless we
file a subpoena and discovery against
youtube to ask them if they're and they
and youtube does this
in response to smears youtube has
deranked and shadow banned many people
hurting their businesses how do you
prove that to a court at the very least
i should be able to sue and say your
honor i can prove what they said is
false
i would like them to be ordered to issue
a correction that's it there you go do
you think that in the correction they
should state that they were also sued to
make a correction so it sets it apart
from ones that they just chose to do yes
it should say a court upon finding of
our defamation has instructed us to
correct the record and make sure our
audience understands
we were wrong
on this count and this count and this
count we apologize for the error they're
going to be on their front page for a
week that could incentivize them to do
it before they get sued so they don't
have to make the say like hey we got
sued also well so this is actually what
happens
organizations will defame you and then
when you move to file a suit they'll
retract in a very weak and pathetic way
to remove standing and then when you go
to a judge they'll say they've already
removed the article okay case dismissed
and then i'm like now i've lost donors
now people won't work here because the
media has threatened because that's like
pulling the bullet out of someone's arm
and being like ah there's no bullet so
there's no proof that i should have a
good example exactly yep no the wound's
still there we need reform on defamation
because i'll tell you this if i made a
mistake if i if if timcast.com published
something incorrect
and someone came to me and said that's
wrong i'd say sorry about that we'll fix
it immediately
and there you go yeah because you're
committed to actually
to the truth so there's no
negative for those who are committed to
the truth if we have a system in which
you can sue someone to force a
correction no i think this is a bigger
question i'd love to hear your thoughts
on this i mean obviously one of the
aspects of our society in our republic
is a free and fair press
um that's meant to actually pursue the
truth to provide transparency that can
then lead to accountability so the
american people understand what's going
on there's accountability
this is the one thing where we clearly
do not have a free and honest press we
have corporate propagandists what are
the steps that are needed to actually
get
them to the point
grudgingly or otherwise where they're
actually focused on trying to be at
least objective on some levels i don't
know that's when clarence clinton went
on
yeah i mean part of it is winning the
market at the same time there have to be
consequences for it yeah because there
are no consequences right now they can
get away with
anything they can say anything they want
and that they can call january 6 people
seditious insurrectionists and there are
no consequences for that when they had
nothing to do with any of that at all
well there are people on january 6 who
have been charged that but they're
innocent until proven guilty but a lot
of these people had doors opened for
them by police i've seen videos yeah
they walked right past the police
yeah on the steps of the capitals no i i
if if we can't get back to the point we
i totally agree with the competition
control the market or get more of a
market share i just gotta we've got to
figure out how there are consequences it
should not be for profit there should be
pain
absolutely absolute pain for what some
of the stuff that they're doing right
now like i mean
they lied about trump every step of the
way yeah almost every single thing ever
the shinzo abe thing i remember that one
when he was feeding the fish
and they they cropped the video so you
could only see trump dumping the food in
and what they crapped out was that
shinzo abe did it first he poured the
food in and looked at trump and then
trump said okay and threw his food in
but they tried to make it seem like
trump did something wrong to insult him
it's insane could you say like any kind
of news organization that would qualify
under protections as a news organization
it has to be a 501c3 no no no
for profit the for-profit news is crazy
because you they just make it up
right it's a problem that's right
so so i'll tell you guys it's really
simple
cnn what's what what should they do
should they spend 100 000 salary to
investigate a story or do they lie
what what makes more money for these
corporations you put out a lie right you
get a million bucks from this viral
story the next day you issue a
retraction here's the best part the
retraction makes money too
now the retraction let's say
someone news news outlet not just cnn
any news outlet writes an article that
goes viral claiming something insane
they get all the ad revenue from it when
they issue their retraction
a small percentage of people will read
the retraction which also has ads on it
so they'll even make money retracting
they don't give back the ad dollars when
they retract the story they keep them
i i think you should be able to sue and
you should get all revenue generated
from the from the false piece oh that's
a good one i love it um i also think
just like mocking these outlets into
oblivion completely
it's like a scary thing to say we have
to destroy faith in like the
journalistic institutions but we do we
need people to just not trust them at
all which means what they'll do is when
they go to sites to read they'll have to
actually read the article they'll have
to see if there's sources and then they
can regain trust in a website they'll be
like okay this site that i've been
reading for a while actually sources
things i'm going to start reading them
there cannot be an immediate assumption
that because it's a journalistic outlet
it's going to be correct it has to be
the opposite it's it's it's it's an
issue of human behavior though yeah i
mean people don't expect articles they
read headlines but i was also going to
say are
like are people really looking for the
truth are they looking for something
that will reinforce their
presuppositions
i mean we're just talking about you know
for the four thousandths whatever time
are they going to get trump it's
reinforcing their biases they just want
to hear what they already believe right
so i don't i don't know i think that's
an interesting question let's talk about
this next door we got this from deadline
the view apologizes after linking
turning point usa to neo-nazi
demonstrators
i don't think the apology was good
enough no it's not they said uh haynes
sarah hayne said so on monday we talked
about the fact that there were openly
and neo-nazi demonstrators outside the
florida student action summit of the
turning point usa group we want to make
clear these demonstrators were gathered
outside the event and that they were not
invited or endorsed by uh invited or
endorsed by turning point usa a turning
point usa spokesman said the group quote
100 condemns these those ideologies and
said turning point you say security
tried to remove the neo-nazis from the
area but could not because they were on
public property also turning point you
say one wanted us to clarify this was a
turning point you say summit and not a
republican party event so we apologize
for anything we said that may have been
unclear on these points this is the
problem it wasn't what they said was
unclear it was what they said was untrue
right i didn't get the original
statement they said that there were
neo-nazis at turning point whoopi
goldberg said initially you let him in
though okay them in so they lied then
they didn't say something right clearly
they lied they come back from commercial
and they're like we got issue of
clarification they they weren't and she
goes they weren't in the building but
they were all you know in the in the in
the mix
for lying not for being unclear it's
different you lied whoopi
maybe maybe she thought it was real and
she said something that she thought was
real she like this is again what would
they should sue
oh yeah this is probably for as much as
money as they can the nazis were
protesting the events right in
opposition to it but one of the ways you
actually get some sort of accountability
is pain
a big believer that there have to be
consequences and sue them yeah because
they can do something
on whoopi's neck like you can't keep
bringing me yeah yeah you can't be doing
this and at some point the legal counsel
is going to come say hey stop you can't
be well they they did this this is the
crazy thing i think they will go after
like another maybe a massive lawsuit
that they lose and settlement
when whitby defamed them they came back
and she said i have to issue a notice
they weren't in the building the
producers clearly went to her and said
you can't lie like that and then she she
they come back from commercial or
whatever and she's like okay everybody
they weren't in the building but maybe
some producers have some moral ethics on
the view still it's not about more or
less about fear
losing your job
and so i think turning point should
still sue because
i'd argue this was not enough
they needed to clarify the people who
were there were actually protesting and
hate turning point usa
there was no connection the groups were
were the turning point you say people
were screaming at them and they were
they were like
yelling at each other the view is just
this is the game they play
you lie you issue a weak retraction and
say we know that you can't handle a
lawsuit so deal with it this is also
like just an expose as usual of the
ignorance that many of these mainstream
outlets shows have of right-wing
politics in general like whenever i even
when i read academic articles about like
the alt-right or something they're all
so unbelievably incorrect like anyone
who calls charlie kirk like far right or
all right it's like you you literally
know nothing about the dynamics of the
right the right know everything about
the dynamics of the left they understand
them inward and outward all the
different factions and groups but
there's it's like a complete blind spot
the right are just like nazis all of
them and did you see the crowd crowder
put out a video where he's talking to
some college students and one guy calls
him alt-right he's like what he's like
what does that mean and then everyone
like there's a black dude there and he's
like crowder's not all right he's like i
watch crowder all the time what are you
talking about and the guy says alt-right
like you and ben shapiro and he's like
ben shapiro's jewish
they don't know what it means they don't
they're they're mindless zombies and
this is the problem they get lied to
by the view and other news outlets and
then they walk around saying things that
make literally no sense but i'll tell
you this if you want to control people
keep them in a constant state of
confusion where they don't know what's
happening as they say the truth shall
set you free whoopi just said that jill
biden should be our surgeon general that
was a while she's a phenomenal doctor
that was a while ago yeah and totally
ridiculous because she's like an
education a doctor an
yeah it's like an educational honorary
honor
i don't know oh she got yeah an honorary
one nice i don't know let me make sure i
uh
i think it was real yeah i think that i
think there is a real skin care doctors
educator educator yeah yeah it's not a
phd it's something else let me see if i
can uh
find it but that's a
going back to the lab
the thing that's
curious to me about the left there's no
actual curiosity
doctor of education okay so it comes
from it's not a phd in the kids edd
that's what she has i think it's more
than that educationist doctor
so you're saying so you're saying that
people on the left in this in this cult
or whatever this is this weird there's
no intellectual curiosity they don't
really want to understand because
from the outset
they're all wrong so why should we have
any curiosity in trying to understand
where they're coming from
so i i mean they literally have no
curiosity about trying to examine any of
our ideas or have a conversation because
our conscience is wrong our beliefs are
wrong our actions are wrong so we don't
need to even engage with you on this at
all we do have an update here from tony
point usa though they say tomorrow join
the protest thursday july 28th 7 a.m
outside gma studios in times square 10
a.m outside the vue studio 320 west 66th
street uh i'll just say this
if you are in times square can you get a
photo of those billboards that we have
up we're really trying to i'm just
kidding yeah get one of me yeah
i haven't seen a photo yet uh i just
want to stress that point though while
y'all are protesting gma and i think
there's a billboard of me above their
building so like this is the point i'm
trying to make with those times square
ads
we're coming for their cultural spaces
we are challenging them we are winning
and they are getting really really angry
remind me again is there is there an ad
for chicken city yes there is okay good
two of them actually two of them okay i
just want to make sure because 96 foot
tall billboards for chicken city but
chicken city gets some love yeah well i
deserve it yeah i want i'm fascinated by
this whole concept great well so the the
general idea with times square is that
our ads are going to be right next to
good morning america and when regular
people look up they're going to see us
on par equal to them and we're going to
call them out as liars and we are going
to be of same status and stature on
equal footing when we do it is that
something you could do like if you knew
there was an ad beside you that was like
for the view or something could you get
like a you know i'm with stupid arrow or
something like you can do that yes you
know
they might reject it right but i think
as long as
i i think most of these companies that
do ads just want money
so when you know i put up a it's this
this billboard we have in times square
is so big i don't know what to do with
it so they're they're going to take down
the ad soon that the run the run is
ending and then they were like we'll
send it to you and i'm like it's 40 feet
tall are you finishing that i wonder if
we could get you like something three
ounces one okay so i'll give you a
couple yeah 15 foot and all going like
three different movies going at once so
the point was that we put that at on top
of the good morning america building so
we've got a 70-foot uh
ad
on the top of the good morning america
building so i wanted everybody to see us
above them and make that point i think
it's good branding good marketing good
brand awareness and all that stuff
as they keep getting dragged keep lying
and failing and screwing up we're going
to be there to take those cultural
spaces back so hash take them over sue
the view which is the tp yeah hashtag
sue the video are you not going to join
me in using a paper cup no no i am not i
will i know this guy thinks he's so much
better than you yeah no no
i'm just
okay
it's disrespectful
it's hydrophobic respect the papi and
there it goes that's right that's it
cheers to the last year
has been the last of the pap yeah i've
been
after it happy happy happy happy
officially costly have they officially
declared that they're suing the view or
is this just like let's just i don't
think press i don't think they said that
yet but hashtag sue the view is the is
the hashtag for the event i think uh i'm
assuming joe hernandez is going to be
down there and so drew if you're out
there uh i look forward to seeing all
the footage in the coverage of what's
going on with people protesting they
should be they should be exciting um i'm
glad to see that uh people on the right
are organizing peaceful protests yeah
and it's punching back yeah yeah i think
this is the one thing that i loved about
trump is that he rejected the premise he
wasn't going to take any he punched back
and i'd like to see this more across the
movement where
you come at us and we will come right
back at you even stronger it's rapid too
like when you're disciplining a dog if
it pees on the ground you don't wait 20
minutes and then come back and yell
because it doesn't know why you're
yelling but if you do it right when it's
doing it it knows not to do that there
needs to be accountability because so
long as these as the left can burn down
buildings without law enforcement
intervening and it's insane i'll tell
you this i think
actually can i just say why hasn't any
uh republican filed a lawsuit to
disqualify joe biden and kamala harris
for running for office for waging
insurrection against the united states
by funding the bail for insurrectionists
on during the summer of love they want
to all that happens is the democrats
come out and scream insurrection for you
know non-stop for months right there's
no insurrection but if that's the game
they want to play they lost these
lawsuits okay well kamala harris
directly bailed out people who were
riding in minnesota and minnesota okay
sewer 14th amendment she waged
insurrection against the united states
she provided material support to people
who engaged in insurrection against this
country
well they don't do it can i but this is
part of the problem
like on a 30 000 foot level on their
side are religious zealots right the
politics for them is their religion they
are religious zealots they are committed
to it by all means necessary they will
have political power we're a bunch of
careerists i'm gonna go to dc i'm gonna
have a nice career at a think tank or in
congress and after 20 30 years be like
hey that was a lot of fun no they're
they're interested in fundamental change
they will do everything they're
committed to it and we're like uh i'm
just here for a good career
we have to completely unless we actually
become more religious zealots on our
side
you're gonna see more of this why aren't
we doing that it's part of why i don't
consider myself conservative because i
do think we need
literal like radical liberal change but
for for good not like zealous ch it
doesn't need to be like my way or the
highway but the system needs to be
drastically altered the federal reserve
has annihilated our economy we need to
take back control of our financials yeah
but i don't think we get back to normal
unless we actually meet
some of their religious solitary with
our own i i i again i tell people we're
not going to get back to normal until we
beat the left the problem unconditional
surrender they there is no
i think we have to come to this this is
not your granddaddy's democratic party
this is an un-american left
that has nothing to do with the founding
ideals i'm not sure where we have common
ground with them nothing well that's
right so i mean how do you actually come
to that point there is no common ground
the only way you get to a common ground
is to beat them into submission i think
god unconditionally common ground on
epstein you know both the left and the
right were like hey what's up with that
someone someone went to jail for
a massive underage prostitution ring but
we don't know who who who are they
selling to right but the left and the
right both agree that there's something
bad going on there epstein didn't let
him let me let me pull up this uh story
here from uh uh well i i have a tweet
here for myself but it's a 538 story 538
says democrats will hold the senate or
at least they're more likely to this is
why i always said when polling looks
good it may mean a red wave but three
months is still an electoral eternity
still 530 could be dead wrong what they
did was forty thousand simulations and
they took a random sampling or it just
has a sample of 100 outcomes showing
that democrats win 52 in 100. i think as
per usual nate silver and his cohorts
are so insanely wrong they've been wrong
over and over again they're probably
wrong now
how could democrats possibly win in a
moment like this now
i do think it is within the realm of
possibility they win i just think the
fact that it's leaning in favor of
democrats makes no sense when we've seen
in florida for instance more republicans
registered to vote than democrats i
think florida's not a battleground state
anymore right when in texas the rio
grande valley republican when you see
safe blue districts in 2020 flip
i don't know how they think this could
possibly happen other than the fair the
one point is there are more republican
seats up for re-election than democrat
seats i i remind people of last year in
virginia a state that biden won by 10
points glenn younkin essentially wins by
two
point swing in a year that will be a
year
we'll have the midterms a year after
that the trajectory has not changed for
joe biden it's gotten worse for
democrats as well
i i tend to think anything that's 12 13
14 15 points is actually in play for
republicans yeah i think it's even to
the point where anything that joe biden
won by 20 points or less in 2020 is
actually competitive have you looked at
gallup's data on this when they talk
about first-term uh congressional losses
typically the democrats have an
advantage and still lose rather rather
well the other thing is you've got i
mean it's hard to be it has happened
very rarely that historical trends are
beaten
on average in the first midterm that a
party holds the white house since world
war ii they've lost 28 house seats and
four senate seats they will have to have
to absolutely defy
historical trends 80 plus year about 80
year historical trends and defy the
economy right gas prices inflation the
other thing i'll remind people issues
don't under
obama's
reuters approval rating was 44.7
october of 2010. we all know what
happened in november of 2010 63 house
seats i think it was seven senate seats
680 state legislative seats i think joe
biden's average on real clear politics
was 37 something or 38. uh joe biden's
aggregate approval rating recently
dropped lower than trump's worst
possible uh aggregate rating so so biden
is actually
has a lower approval rating at its worst
point than trump ever did so go i mean
obama's party got clobbered in the 2010
midterms and he's running about six
seven points ahead of where biden is
right now i mean there's just a lot of
different dynamics that are all fully
falling into place i have a hard time
believing that republicans aren't going
to pick up 35 40 seats in the house i
tend to think on
the probably 53-47 republican majority
in the senate
i think you guys are underestimating how
much people really want ukraine to have
40 billion dollars for vogue photo
shoots aren't we up to 50 years 3
billion or something i can't remember
that's a good point i think they really
liked those vogue photo shoots right
guys they were like you know what that
was my tax dollars hard at work
i i just think at a certain point the
corporate propaganda machine cannot
overcome gas
like msnbc can scream all day and night
and there may be some guy sitting in his
launcher being like wow trump's so awful
then he gets up to go to the you know go
to work he goes to the gas station stops
and looks at that number and just starts
crying well the monmouth poll recently
had the four top issues that were most
important to voters it's all economic
yes inflation groceries
you know you know where abortion falls
on gallup's polling of one percent yeah
well one percent of people think it's
the most important issue have you seen
what rasmussen's been doing which i
think is really interesting the top
eight issues for voters the top eight
issues i won't call mainstream media
corporate propagandists there's no
correlation at all between the top eight
issues at all not even close i mean for
the corporate propagandists it's climate
change it's january 6th it's all this
other stuff for the actual voters it's
economy inflation gas all of these
things real people issues yeah real
people issues and i think it's that i
tell people the closer you get to an
election the trajectories harden
and we're pretty much into august we're
just
what 13 weeks out from the the midterms
these trajectories unless something
absolutely apocalyptic happens
these trends of biden's going to have
worse approval inflation's not changing
all of these things and you're going to
come in november 8th and go
i am absolutely getting clobbered
in the economy and these guys want to
tell me that somehow climate change
january 6th i should have abortion on
demand all the way up to the point of
birth wait a minute you're not
addressing my day-to-day issues here get
out there there's some things that the
political gaslighting can't seem to
overcome and that money stuff is one of
them i remember in canada when trudeau
started bringing in the oh we're going
to freeze people's bank accounts for
supporting the truckers
they immediately reversed all rhetoric
on that as soon as canadians started
going straight to their bank and
withdrawing tons of money out into cash
because they were freaking out the banks
started shutting down atm machines they
started preventing withdrawals and they
were like holy all right all right back
pedal back pedal back pedal this isn't
good so i think yeah when voters start
seeing
oh my gosh i'm not going to be able to
pay for my life then it's going to hurt
the politicians and then hopefully
there'll be some damn change because we
need it yeah i was thinking we could
default on the interest of the federal
reserve
and then say we'll pay you back federal
reserve
we're going to return our federal
reserve notes and then give people
you know a u.s bank cryptocurrency in
exchange and everyone will lose 20
percent of the money they turn in
uh as some sort of currencies
as a massive reset you have either that
or just keep your us dollars and they'll
be worth nothing so it's up to you you
can turn them in and get one percent
back why get eighty percent because the
people because that'll give a
diminishing return to the very wealthy
so the poorer you are the less you lose
so it'll kind of somewhat balance out
this percentage loss is a percentage
lost but if you have a million 20
percent is 200 000 if you have a
thousand twenty percent is and that you
know and that's relatively meaningful to
a rich person and it's the end of the
world for a poor person if you've got a
hundred you could you could do a j curve
as well you could have a scaling uh if
you've got if you that's why we do a
progressive text if you've got 100 bucks
and someone says we're taking 20 of
those dollars away from you you're like
that's my dinner on friday if you've got
a million bucks they take 200 grand
you're like i got a hundred thousand i
don't know yeah i'm open to a scaling
return uh uh diminishment but we need
some sort i i don't know a massive reset
to actually get out of this yeah fed
reserve whatever they're doing what was
it three
point seven five rate hike today three
the fourth time in this country
point seven five point seven [ __ ]
there's no there's that's not even close
to addressing what's happening i saw
someone tweet out that's probably gonna
have to be like a 20-point hike or
something no no to actually stop it i
mean that's what they did in the 80s
didn't they yeah i think it was was it 8
20 yeah something like that with carter
yeah i mean you have to go massive
drastic action i guess what you're
talking about is a massive reset to say
hey we have to do something
very dramatic at this point to stop well
i tell you man people need to learn how
to tend to their own chickens get space
to do so grow some vegetables because
learn how to process deer like
yeah yeah because the time may come you
know look we've been living in a golden
age we have we've uh the the my lifetime
i was thinking about this where it's
like i need to find a job i'll go find a
job you find a job then you get paid 10
bucks an hour or something you're living
in in the city maybe it's 12 bucks and
then you're paying your rent and there's
no conflict there's no there's there's
no fighting other than you know crime
here and there that stuff exists and
then i'm just like man
every other generation throughout
history people would just randomly die
like life was dangerous
you'd go out and you'd be like gotta go
get the water and then you'd fall in the
river and uh you'd stub your toe and
then be like oh i'm it's infected now
i'm gonna die that's how but now we have
all these modern luxuries we've secured
our we had secured borders to a certain
degree and so we our generation grew up
with with little to no conflict
now this is what you get from it
we uh you know good times make weak men
weak men make bad times
and so giving control of the economy to
rockefeller and j.p morgan in 1913
basically
people just got became their their
weakness just their deferment of their
responsibility of monetary control was
the weakness that's brought us to this
stage
i don't know man it's a lot of things
it's a lot of things i think um we've
got cultural decay
is a huge component of it i think but
but but i was thinking about
this recently we're self-governing
republic but our founders didn't mean
that we govern ourselves it's we govern
ourselves
and i think we've lost that concept of
how does the individual govern himself
or herself
completely lost that concept it starts
with family i think this is something
i've had to like really you know swallow
the red pill on lately is i was raised
in a really good family with really good
community and when people spoke to me
they told me the truth
my parents told me the truth they
weren't lying they weren't doing
underhanded things and that's how i
learned to interact with other people
and then i go out into the wider world
and i have no concept of people are
going to lie to me people are going to
do messed up things people are going to
try to set me up for failure and so i'm
interacting in the world in this way
that i learned at home and it's
absolutely screwing me over and the only
way to survive in the wider larger world
is for me to become like everyone else
and learn how to lie learn how to be
underhanded or learn how to spot it and
you don't really have a choice so when
people come up in broken homes and they
see their parents lying to them they see
them lying to each other they see them
just doing awful behavior they learn
that's the way to survive in the world
and that's what our world has become
it's the product of a lot of broken
homes and people learning that lying is
the only way to get by but broken homes
you know i think to your point is not
just about poor homes it's about parents
who are just dejected and removed from
their kids or
letting their kids do whatever they want
without there's no discipline right no
no strategy no expectations um
participation trophies
where is the parent to be like you lost
son because you weren't good enough
train harder and you can be better
instead it's like i want my kid to have
a trophy too it's not fair and then the
kid cries gets a free trophy and thinks
i didn't have to do anything to get this
yeah winning is not the trophy winning
is the work winning is doing the work to
win being able to win is is the real the
process
i mean the way i see it is you know
people often say when they come hang out
here they're like wow you know look at
this thing that you've built and i'm
like i don't know man i wake up every
day and i just add one more thing to
what i'm doing sure if you came and
looked at this facility now you'd be
like how did all this happen and i'm
like
this room didn't used to be here that
room didn't used to be there that guitar
didn't used to be there it's like we
walk up one day and we're like oh yeah
we'll put a ian puts a rock on the table
now ian's got like 50 rocks on the table
they're everywhere and it's just like
one step at a time you slowly get to
that point and you you have to treat
life in my opinion that's how you treat
it the there's the ends don't justify
the means because you never meet the end
if every day you live your best day you
like i'll tell you this people are like
i want to lose weight i did not lose
weight recently trying to lose weight i
just decided to eat better today so one
day i was like i didn't eat any sugar or
grains
i'm just not going to then the next day
i was like well i shouldn't start now i
had a great day yesterday i should just
eat healthy today and then sure enough i
lose a bunch of weight the problem with
politics is like the people treat the
victory as getting the most votes so
that they get the office and they get
the scepter but like
that makes people do underhanded things
to get the scepter and
that's not real victory for us we need
people to be their best and then
whichever one of them is chosen even the
one that isn't chosen still wins because
they did their best
but like you're saying that doesn't seem
to be how reality works because the
strong take or or whatever is going on
there's not enough to go around yeah i
kind of view it as like life hacking if
you're playing by all the rules you're
just gonna kind of stay in this you know
minimum wage kind of average salary
probably under 100k and then there's
people that will like morality hack and
they'll get to a next level you can lie
to people you can cheat people you can
get to all these higher positions when
you can like hack the system of morality
and um that's that's how you get these
like elites like epstein that are like
oh we're just gonna literally sell
children we're going to sell other
humans dude we're going to make a ton of
money we're going to have tons of black
people
on these
politicians we're going to be able to
control the world because we've morality
hacked we're not bound by any freaking
rules we can do whatever we want to
anyone on this planet i want to talk
about cultural decay
and we have this story here from the
daily mail
women hikers throw the kitchen sinks at
gender stereotypes as they climb
scaffold pike with washing stations
attached to their backs in fight for
equality wow congratulations to emma
woodhall april wilson and xena clark for
carrying
kitchen sinks
on top of a mountain uh okay i just i
have so much to say about this for one i
hope everybody's laughing a lot right
now looking at this image of women with
sinks strapped to their backs
i honestly think this reinforces the
gender stereotype
it's like
you went hiking but instead of just
hiking you have brought a sink with you
reinforcing that you are to be around it
that's a terrible idea
i really respect it you know it's been
difficult for me to figure out how to do
shows like this when i have to stay in
my kitchen as you know i also under the
table have a kitchen sink
oh right did you finish the dishes yet
so this is like a really
working on it but so so here's your feet
here's what i see here there's there's a
couple big things in this story one
people are insane
right no and i mean like i mean in kind
of a colloquial sense like
there's no logic behind this it's a
stunt they're trying to get attention
they got it the media wrote about it
that's a good workout too yeah that's
great it's a good workout it's a good
one it's like a farmer's walk up a
mountain that's true that's true well
that's a fair that's that's a good
that's a positive right
my point is
why would someone do something so absurd
clicks instagram likes they're trying
they're peacocking they're trying to
flutter their fathers back notice me
they're doing nothing to actually target
patriarchy or whatever they think is
going on they're making no cultural
change no political change
this is the perfect example in my
opinion of the narcissistic vapid youth
i should say youth i mean these people
are 40. but like 40 yeah this generation
that doesn't understand the problem
doesn't have a solution but stands on
top of a pedestal holding a kitchen sink
so that people notice them and they can
claim they're doing something this
exemplifies all of it listen you don't
you don't know what it's like to be so
attention starved
they're dying here
they're gonna be hospitalized in two
weeks if they don't get more clicks what
is the purpose of their movement here
what were they doing protesting
patriarchy is that the vague yes yeah
that's the i think
numbers go gender stereotypes protesting
gender stereotypes by reinforcing them
with a kitchen sink they're worth more
than this i feel like they should have
carried porcelain sinks yeah so pretty
long heavier yeah it's been it's been
52 years
right since the since the start of
i guess the gender equality stuff 70 was
around the time we started seeing more
women enter the workforce
52 years
but no matter how much they win and they
are winning they're more likely to go to
college less likely to be homeless
millennial women and younger make more
money than millennial men they're still
acting like they're the oppressed
victims well to an extent i do think
people hate women now more than ever but
it's their fault
[Music]
i would say you know when i was growing
up when we would like banter back and
forth like even when i played a bit of
video games when i grew up the jokes
were always like go make me a sandwich
or something now they're like go die in
a hole you like slur like people i i
think the gender dynamics have become so
just escalated because there's so much
tension and hatred because we've been so
pitched against each other where it's
like oh i didn't get that job because a
woman just got that position because she
was a woman she got to become the
fighter pilot in the military she got
the professor position she got the
scholarship whatever it is and now
instead of just seeing women as humans
because feminism was like okay we're
equal now men see them as this like
force that's trying to dominate them and
it's become really sinister it's quite
sad it's quite sad to see us pitched
against each other so much
i suspect that feminism is a lot like so
i don't really care for unions anymore
because they've served their purpose and
now they're done i think that feminism
is exactly the same they accomplished
what they set out to and we had richie
mcginnis's mom on the show and she was
talking about the stuff that the
legitimate struggles that they actually
had to get women to have equal rights to
men and for the ability to work that's
great that's fine we have all that now
we're done we don't need feminists
anymore i really don't think we do and
we're doing stuff like strapping sinks
to our backs lightweight sinks for the
record so it's not like they're doing
any kind of military drill they're
lightweight yeah well they're like
they're like porcelain yeah they're
metal aluminum i've carried things like
that before so they're like aluminum
yeah and it's it's not disappointing
actually it's just they didn't commit to
it yeah they really didn't yeah
honestly the back of their legs while
they're walking yeah no feminism
completely unnecessary well disappointed
they wore shoes i do believe we're
intellectual equals men and women which
is important to to maintain like what is
that what does that mean that we're both
capable of doing math problems eq like
no no man or woman coming out of the
womb is going to be better or worse
because of their gender in in
intellectual companies men on average
are going to be better at things like
maths but i do think that it's obviously
there are women that can meet and rise
to that level um and i also think it's
really taken for granted uh different
types of intelligence like eq emotional
intelligence i do think women tend to
have higher emotional intelligence than
men what does that mean though um
like ability to read people process
emotions and social situations um and
these things are studied quite
extensively so it's important to see
averages and differences but then judge
people as individuals yeah ian there's
something called the greater male
variability hypothesis which shows that
males are more likely to be extremely
stupid but more likely to be extremely
smart so when you look at the highest
and lowest end of the bell curve for
male talent be it math be it basketball
they they so here's the here's the issue
when it comes to the fortune 500s
of the however many companies that exist
in the world
500 get that top slot the fortune 500
the biggest the best
so when you have when you have 100 men
and 100 women
and
on the female bell curve
five percent of women are really dumb
ten percent are below average and then
you've got uh what seventy percent
average then fifteen slightly above
average and five percent
my math is weird but i know what you
mean yeah ten percent ten percent twenty
thirty right 70 in the middle yeah so
the issue for men is that you're going
to have 50 in the middle
way more dumb people but way more smart
people
so if you have
uh out of 100 guys
10 in the highest end of the bell curve
and then out of the women five in the
highest end of the bell curve and even
then the highest high point is male
now do a top ten ranking in a ability to
run a business and guess what's gonna
happen you're gonna have nine dudes in
one chick or not even that there are 10
guys and all have been competing against
them all the women may lose that's not
anomalous you only got 15 people
competing in all likelihood the top
eight slots will be men and then two
will be women and people say how does
that make sense there's 50 men you know
50 100 men and 100 women should be equal
shouldn't it no
because you will also have substantially
more really really dumb men this is why
i think so many women think guys are
dumb because there's a whole lot of
really dumb guys relative to women
equals not is a very vague term in that
it doesn't mean the same doesn't mean
we're the same and and i think in the
past the extremes have dictated the the
generalizations like okay eight out of
ten ceos are men therefore men make
better ceos but that's not you know
across the board i think you need to
make space for the women who are good at
that because i do
there are women that are not going to be
the norm they're not going to want to be
mothers they're going to want to pursue
careers they're going to find that
really really fulfilling and you need to
make space for that and as long as
there's space for that you're fine what
we're doing now unfortunately though is
we're trying to force women into a
larger space than they even need well i
i i would put put it this way
luxuries eventually become necessities
so cell phones for instance
when cell phones first came out it was a
novelty seeing the guy with that really
big phone and it's like if i'm in this
one block radius i can call my work then
you got car phones and all of a sudden
now it's a luxury you had the
opportunity to make a call from your
vehicle most people still operated under
you call me when i'm at the office or at
home
when cell phones became ubiquitous all
of a sudden now you got two workers
one with a cell phone one without who's
getting hired oh dude the cell phone
hands down i can call you at any time i
can i can get answers to questions hire
the person with a cell phone that luxury
became a necessity and now you're not
going to get hired if you don't have one
women entering the workforce it started
out as women who want to work can work
no one's saying they shouldn't you know
we're changing things
and then once women started entering the
workforce
you now had dual income households
competing against single income
households and this so all of a sudden
you have a business that says listen
we've got a dual income household they
can take the job for 30 000 a year you
know because the husband and wife are
both working sorry i know you have a
family but you need too much money i'm
gonna hire the the woman now you've got
double the workforce overnight without a
doubling of the work uh supply and then
you see
suppression of wages you see collapse
and eventually then you come to a point
where women have to work it started out
as they can if they want to and now it's
better otherwise you're broke because no
one can afford it yeah i was thinking
about what you said about emotional
quotient eq and iq being different like
i'll have a conversation with when my
girlfriend's involved in conversations
like sometimes tim and i'll get into it
and it'll be like it'll get heightened
and it'll get fast and loud and she's
like i don't want to be around the tone
and i'm like what i'm not even thinking
about the tone i'm thinking about what
we're saying so to the man to our brains
it's like the information is is more
important but to her it's like it's the
feeling of the situation is altering the
way you're producing the information
and this is the big myth that
conservatives often struggle with we do
the facts don't care about your feelings
feelings are more important than facts
feelings are way more important feelings
don't care about your facts yeah
absolutely and we need to take that into
account we need what makes people
motivated to do anything is how they
feel anything political the only reason
they care about the facts is because i
love my family and i want to protect my
family so i'm going to go look into the
facts to see what the best ways are to
do that i mean let's be real if if uh
if your kid some of your child
did something illegal i think most
people would be like i have to protect
my son at all costs yep yeah like they
will they know it's wrong they know it's
against the law don't care my kid's not
going to jail but that's one of the
problems with conservatives we go to the
head first not the heart yes yeah you
got to figure that i think it's
fascinating ben shapiro's tweet while i
respect it you know facts don't care
about your feelings like a hundred
thousand retweets goes viral like crazy
when i saw that i was just like yeah but
feelings don't care about your facts
right and i think that's substantially
more important to the conversation i'll
be it's wrong
but the issue is if you go to someone
and tell them like i don't know michael
brown didn't have his hands up obama's
doj came out and said that was not true
they'll just get angry because your
facts are meaningless to how they feel
about it but this is one of the actual
principles of the less organizing appeal
to the heart first to put the hands and
feet into motion yeah they figured it
out like again
appeal to the heart get people into
motion sometimes the facts line up
sometimes they don't but it doesn't
matter you've got people motivated in
the right direction do what you want
them to do i keep thinking about god
like the emotions attached to really
believing in that that
and like that that's similar to what
people in occult will do like and i'm
talking about people that are like in
the media cult whatever you are called
on the left or whatever like it's so
emotionally dreamy because they truly
believe in it and i know that emotion is
there in people on all sides
the the issue is they they they may not
believe in it and their brain doesn't
let them ever even consider it they feel
physical pain it's like what brandon
strzok told us that when he was first
breaking out of the left and he saw the
video of trump doing the arm thing it
was physically painful to be proven
wrong so there are a lot of people they
don't they don't actually believe it
when you present them with facts and
hand them the sheet showing it they get
really angry because they know deep down
their brain is telling them this
is true but we cannot accept it we
cannot a lot of them have personal
trauma connected to their politics as
most people do you know you look with
feminists and this is something i wish i
acknowledged more when i was younger and
kind of challenging the feminist
movement is they they had bad
relationships with their father a
horrible abusive relationship or
whatever and they're projecting that
personal experience onto the broader
political discourse because it's easier
to deal with something that's far away
from you
than to really like look inward at your
own personal pain so they'll try to
fight it through these larger political
battles it's the same with trump trump
is just the representation of their
christian parents that were distant and
at work all the time and not talking to
them and they hate it and they're
rejecting and rebelling against it and a
lot of people had those personal
experiences with their family where they
grew up in a you know christian
conservative household that they're
fighting back against they had a bad
experience with a man or whatever it
might be and
and that's their emotional place they're
in and i think we do as much as they do
really stupid stuff and really wreck our
society we do need to see the left as
humans that are just you know very
confused in a lot of ways and we do need
to reach out to them on an emotional
level and try to pull them back from
that edge i know uh we don't like
humanizing the left but we have to i
don't disagree i just don't know where
you find the middle ground with them no
i don't think that's in you no you need
to feel it if you cry openly
out of joy out of belief not out of
sadness or pain but like out of truly
believing it people resonate the middle
ground is not in arguments and political
discussions because feelings don't care
about facts the middle ground is in
we uh i brought this up several days now
but we're launching shows at timcast.com
i think right now it's like 80 of the
content we produce is not political okay
the overwhelming majority of it is not
political at all because i don't want to
go to somebody who is only peripherally
involved in politics and very angry and
start yelling politics at them i want
them to be like hey man i don't know
about all that stuff why don't you come
hang out we'll tell a ghost story we'll
sit around the campfire we'll have
marshmallows that is so much more
attractive to many people now
politics has become pop culture
the view talking about turning point usa
there are people who are turning on tv
for entertainment and then being
bludgeoned over the head with ideology
my attitude is this twofold one let's
just hang out have a good time have
pizza not talk about that stuff put
these people in an environment where
they're away from that and something
interesting happens when they're
dedicating their time to watching
sitcoms or or um like you know we've
tails from the inverted world and we're
launching a bunch of other shows
they're not they're not in a world of
pain anymore
now they're to look back and they're
going to see people screaming but trump
a trump and then go that made me feel
miserable can i just listen to the ghost
stories because right now i'm just
interested we got to give them a space
that is just not overly political but
the other thing is
when we create cool fun stuff and we're
doing back flips into foam pits then
we're all all over here cheering and
high fiving each other and being like
come on come party and hang out we're
doing back flips sounds fun it's a
bouncy castle come hang out we don't
want to talk about that painful stuff
it's an escape i think that's what we
got to do to help people break away from
the cult yeah so many conservatives have
just portrayed themselves as we sit and
we read books all day and pray all day
you know praying's good you should do it
but you're we're humans too
we're scared to show that but this is
the thing about like turning point usa
is like i think they do great work but
they're all suits
you know like cpac tp usa these big
events and i'm like
grow your hair out you know look man
you're not you're you're connected to
your nervous system there's a certain
kind of person
that you know uh believe uh i i
idealizes facts don't care about your
feelings
it's it's correct you know facts matter
more than how you feel about them in my
opinion but politically feelings matter
more to the average person so my
attitude is just like where is the space
for people who are sick and tired of the
woke cult who just want to watch some
guy do a backflip escapism
just relax you know escapism here's what
happened i'll tell you this we're making
we're working on a video game we showed
you guys the the video game earlier
today
we're working on a video game out here
and it's because i'm like
people want to play a video game and
what happens all of a sudden it's
wokeness they make battlefield or what
was it called was it battlefield
battlefield where the woman had like
purple hair and a and like a prosthetic
or something and everyone's like what
what is going on
every movie's got to be some political
message every show has got to be
political as much as i'm a fan of the
show the boys it's just come on stop
hitting me over the head with this stuff
does every show have to be like this
resident evil it's like come on yeah i
don't even think oh are you gonna say i
was just i don't think it's escapism
when people want to like i like
off-roading i like going out shooting
swimming every other day i don't think
any of that's escapism i think that's
how humans are supposed to live um life
is lived in the in-between we're not
supposed to be thinking about politics
every second we're supposed to be
actually spending time with friends
family and it's okay for people who are
political personalities to go out and
show that side of themselves to say
actually
this is what's important to me and this
is how i want you to be living that's
why i care about politics so you don't
have to worry about the government
infringing on your ability to do these
things and actually live your life with
your families so we have to care about
politics but it's not what we're
supposed to be doing 24 7. agreed i
think about like the universe and
consciousness and like sometimes people
like oh he's a psychedelic tripster
think you know wasting yeah get out of
here but like it's self-preservation and
the preservation of our species because
every 20 000 years this planet gets hit
by comets you know or however 40 000
years everything's reset everybody's
wiped out so we need to get off this
planet if we want to keep having
conversations about politics and that's
i'm a big advocate of communicating
about politics about social structure
but we have got to focus on science you
create a space
where like you know tim cast has a news
outlet as well right but we we've been
investing heavily in tales from the
inverted world and i will just tell
everybody for those that are interested
in knowing the the click-through rates
the the cost per click all that stuff
has been ridiculous like so we're doing
ads this is uh shane cashman he went
down to georgia investigating lost
confederate gold it is only political in
that sense of the history but for the
most part it's just his journey meaning
witches ufos someone threatened to kill
him because he's trying to find this
gold it is just outside of the realm of
modern political culture war stuff and
the the click-through rate is like
double or triple what we see in other
ads we've only recently started doing ad
stuff and i'm like this is good news
regular people
when you go on facebook you see them
inundated with memes about politics
anger and hatred and it's like let's
let's promote this
and pull them out of that space and then
allow that kind of hatred to evaporate
for a little bit but here's the best
part timecast.com has a news section
with true facts
so if they're doing nothing but watching
msnbc and getting wrapped into it we
pull them out and offer them a space to
just relax and watch ghost stories or
sitcoms or chicken city and then if they
end up seeing the news the news is
neutral straightforward and fact-driven
what do you do when you're not involved
thinking about politics what are your
main focuses
hunting oh what kind of stuff what's
your hunting style like uh deer i'll do
everything crossbow muzzleloader
crossbar we got deer out here like crazy
every night when i go back down there's
a bunch of deer in my lawn
brother-in-law and i actually my son uh
we hunt we'll do we'll do the
knock them down in the woods field dress
them
bring them in we process them in the
barn
what do you what do you so when you get
a deer like do you you make a bunch of
different kinds of meat you make like
jerky salami i usually my brother-in-law
awesome he literally will process almost
everything on the deer either you know
give the ribs to the dogs and eat the
marrow i don't i mean like do people
like we'll take the deer marrow maybe
yeah
i don't i literally take the back strap
i take the inner tenderloins i take the
rumps and i typically make those into
either a stew or i'll do biltong
or i'll do jerky
tenderloin it's a south african
form of jerky
it's really good deer tenderloin is that
similar in any way to like standard cow
or um i mean it's the inner tenderloin
is the best part of the deer and
i soak it in whiskey garlic salt and
pepper overnight
i beat it out
and then i fry it with some fresh eggs
from our chickens that sounds amazing
and you do it right it's superb i i had
a friend who brought me to this dude's
house once and he they did a full
process they had every kind of like meat
you could make from a deer i was like
we've been done we have done my my
brother-in-law was like we've got to do
some sausage so we did you know half of
it is
sausage half as venison and then we did
jalapeno and we did cheddar
amazing oh stuffed you stopped yeah we
stuffed our own sausage you know he
comes through the intestines yeah i like
your answer to his question you're like
trying to find what's your like
non-political chill thing you're like oh
yeah when i'm not destroying leftists
i'm i'm shooting i'm killing things in
the woods
what about turkeys turkeys are terrible
yeah have you ever eaten any wild
turkeys nope they're awful yeah wild
what's what's bad about it well they're
extremely lean meats
and i i probably screwed up on how i
prepared it i probably i've heard people
that you just gotta slow cook it like
crazy to get it to where it's edible
um what else do i do that when i'm not
shooting things or destroying leftists
i'm i'm actually big into horticulture
i've got my orchards i've got orchards
what are you growing peaches apples
cherries um
got a raised with a raised bed with
blueberries what percentage of your uh
diet would you say comes from your own
production
not
enough i mean i want to get to the point
where i don't know during deer season no
not half
we've got the eggs we've got some
venison the only problem is there's not
many people in the household that love
venison so it's like
yeah well you eat what you eat you know
what i mean we brought you a deer back
time to eat it yeah we do i mean the
part of the other raised bed is like a
jalapeno uh tomato poblano peppers we're
doing salsa garden okay you gotta stop
describing food no it's amazing
we have we do have fun i do other things
outside of politics and it's actually i
mean it
it does actually
like you get away from it and and you
become a full you i fully realize you
know all aspects of your humanness i
think people should uh people listening
especially now should start figuring out
how to um
create a larger percentage of their own
uh i totally agree yeah no this is one
of the things i'm trying to fight we've
got
30 some acres
20 of it's 21 of its forest and we're
trying to figure out how can i make the
other 10 acres or so productive yeah and
what can i do with those we've got too
many eggs here because we now have like
30 chickens and the new ones are
starting to lay my my wife is a chicken
lady we are going to have like
uh
so here's how it works the raccoons just
pick them off one by one usually they
just murder them right they don't even
need them they suck the blood out of
them they're literally vampires yeah the
foxes will come in and it's a massacre
in like 10 minutes oh is there him fun
they're just killing him killing kill
and killing him they'll drag a couple
off eat them but there's just you i went
down one time it was probably 3 or 3 30
in the afternoon everybody was fine had
to go back up to the house the barns
maybe i don't know 100 yards below the
house went up back back to the house did
some stuff came back i'm not kidding 30
40 minutes later
like 15 of them were dead wow fox had
just come and nailed them all
i don't think i was able to kill that
one have you ever shot the foxes that
come i have yeah the this
one of them got away partly because the
neighbors have horses and it was not a
clear shot so i held back which is the
right thing to do but the other one i
shot and then um
there'd been some raccoons shooting your
neighbor's horse yeah no that's that
would be fun yeah no raccoons you know
raccoons yes they are nasty two barrels
of a 12 gauge takes care of them we got
it we got a raccoon problem we set up a
trap we uh we took care of one of them
yeah the the so i mean we have so this
is what's what's worrying is that we
have uh we have we have dogs and they're
still coming around which they shouldn't
be because
our open area right now the chickens is
not particularly large but
i saw a fox so we have a cat his name is
bucko
and i'm i'm recording one day this is a
couple months ago and he's sitting
in the middle in the field and from from
my studio i can see the whole backyard i
can see the chickens like really wide
view and i see him sitting to the middle
of the field in a loaf like cats do when
a very gaunt looking fox starts creeping
out of the brush and slowly moving
towards them and my cat being dumb just
stood there staring and then i was like
i'm in the middle of recording a segment
20 like 15 minutes in like so that's
nearly done for my morning segment and i
had no i i stopped i got up and i ran
outside and started yelling and the fox
did not run and i did you know jump over
the fence or jump over the railing and
like run down and the fox took off uh
i'm worried the fox was starving that's
why i was coming out of the property
fearless of the dog and going after my
cat yeah and my cat's too stupid to run
away from it just saying that cat was
gonna ruin and that's face up no that
fox
right and then when the fox ran off cat
just looks at me and then just looks
back at the woods and just doesn't even
blink do you have kaya wolves out here i
don't know we have coyotes well so
there's
there's been a crossbreed that's
developed between wolves and coyotes
they're called kaya wolves
we have modern property i haven't heard
them recently what do they like they
look like small wolves wow they don't
look i mean we had ton i grew up in
kansas we had a ton of coyotes
very like obvious coyotes these coyote
wolves look like small wolves are they
vicious like like wolves yeah i mean
they're pretty aggressive i'll go
through the forest i haven't seen
anything recently but you'll go through
and it's it's literally like a pack of
them hit a deer and there's parts
everywhere i've been thinking lately are
raccoons a kind of animal that we would
be better off wiping out like making
extinct or do they do any value to the
system trash pandas they're kind of cute
no have you guys ever seen that video of
the uh guy's dog being attacked by a
raccoon and he's like above a stairwell
and he grabs the raccoon and just like
flips it around and throws it down the
stairs and all you see are these little
glowing eyes disappearing into the abyss
no no okay it's a great video you gotta
find that one we're gonna go to super
chats
ladies and gentlemen if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends we are going
to have a members only uncensored show
at timcast.com coming up
coming up at about 11 p.m so check that
out
and uh let's grab some of your super
chats
all right we got a whole bunch of super
chats say audio buzz audio
audio
you're good now all right let's see john
r says
the accounting firm that prepares my
taxes wants me to sign a document
stating that i'm not a russian citizen
russian national nor do i currently
reside in russia as it and if my status
changes to let them know immediately wtf
you know what that's really weird
ja says can't believe you haven't
mentioned rip averse comics yet tim
we've mentioned it several times we
talked about yesterday paypal froze
eric july's account or whatever like a
good portion of it what the status of
that is that's crazy
all right let's see
ian hall says jeremy is a legend i loved
that ad placement chill for coffee brand
coffee so another free ad spot mr
quartering
for people that that didn't get the ad
uh at the beginning of the show and ad
played for jeremy's coffee it's
specifically tailored to tim too yeah
hey guys about to watch tim cast uh buy
my coffee all right have fun watching
tim see you later and then it goes i
didn't know you could still do that
that's awesome i knew that you used to
be able to run ads specifically on one
video i didn't know you could still do
it but yeah he's like before you watch
tim's video go buy my coffee and then my
attitude is like thank you for the money
jeremy this show is sponsored by the
quartering apparently and coffee brand
coffee
although the funny thing is jeremy could
just reach out and be like hey how much
for an ad spot i guess
and i think it's cheaper actually when
we do it direct
because youtube takes a huge cut you
know
but then he'd get the full viewership
how about that coffee brand coffee you
know what we're gonna open our own
coffee business no probably not maybe a
coffee house that serves coffee brand
coffee
all right
let's grab some super chats
what is this uh raymond g maga stanley
jr says i'm angry tim so mad at
capitalism the healthy white sis males
i'm so
ut oh no dang it i just ished my pants
that's it i'm joining antifa
so that was a segment i did earlier
there was this antifa woman who was
right or arrested on suspicion of
rioting and felony assault she had
previously wrote about how she has long
cove and it caused her to crap her pants
and then i was like look i know a lot of
people see that they probably laugh when
they hear that story but my attitude is
like imagine you're like poor
you know a lot of people probably are
and then one day you're at work and poop
just comes out of your butt you can't
control it you're going to be really
really angry but who can you be mad at
so what happens is these people have
this pent-up rage from their lives they
can't control then someone comes along
and says i know who's causing all your
problems it's dave chappelle
this is probably why these people go out
and protest nonsensical things and it's
not it's not just because this woman
pooped her pants but it's a really good
example look at this everyone's making
fun of her now they're all they're all
laughing imagine what that person's
feeling knowing that this is your life
now you've got to wear diapers you're in
the middle of work and you've got poop
all over your butt you have to work
through that
yeah and who can you who do you get mad
at
whoever fed you that gun right no it's
yourself you can only be mad at yourself
well it was long coveted are you are you
mad at the virus dude so what happens is
the chinese how can they do this
someone comes along and says all you
should have universal health care and
the reason you don't is because of these
bigots and transphobes in the far right
and then they say okay
that's who i can be mad at somebody
because i'm mad and they give them a
target to be mad at that's what happens
and i think the uh i think the poop
story makes it very very apparent
because without something so overt you
don't know about their trauma their
relationships with their fathers or
whatever all you see is some person
you're like what are you mad about it's
like well maybe they're met about
something they have no one to be mad at
yeah so this is this story exemplifies
that in my opinion
imagine you'd be mad too
your point is profound but the context
of it just makes it impossible to lose
well the context is on purpose right
because it makes people you know yeah i
searched to poop their pants i would i
would advise everyone certainly i'm like
10.
why am i laughing i didn't click
is uh this is the real world this is
where we're at this is where we are
waffles sensei says i had an epiphany
last night ian i believe in the graphene
now the process you speak of in
separating the carbon out of the
chemicals in the air you're literally
talking about mimicking the process of
the trees and plants it's genius
innovation
hell yes you know we can pull the carbon
dioxide out of the atmosphere and the
methane and then put it on deposit onto
palladium or probably other metals and
then um
take the carbon out so essentially mine
the air for carbon dioxide fix it how
are we doing that uh australian
scientists have been doing it so we can
start to mimic the process i want to
bring it to the political sphere and get
the government involved so we can start
funding research and development and
start selling this stuff are you
familiar with graphene
no i'm not really familiar it sounds
like trees on steroids
it's a uh single atomic layer of carbon
yes this is a hexagonally latticed and
it's a wonder material so maybe we'll
see some more in the future but 21st
century building material like steel
it's conductive and capacitive like
batteries
let's read some super chats
jamie nunyabiz says the j6 trials will
help because of the absurdity of the
content and how specific people like ray
apps not getting any charges but also
labeled as a victim
agreed you see they included me in it
jamie raskin put a video of me in it oh
he did it was me reading a news article
and they they edited it in such a way to
make it seem like i was telling people
to go to dc
yeah total fabrication
and this is this is why i'm saying like
i think the country is on the verge of
imploding when you've got sitting
members of congress
smearing and defaming and just trying to
destroy for no other reason to destroy
i'm like how long can this thing last
now i'm not saying people will die like
you know some people might in conflict
we've seen that already what i'm saying
is it's just going to get more
tumultuous whatever that means i don't
know get some chickens and get out of
the cities i guess
yep yep
all right ss penguin says hello tim cast
crew i just wanted to say i love you all
and if you ever want to add to chicken
city may i humbly suggest ducks they're
hilarious they are
i was told they have to be raised
together though can i bring you a
canadian goose
no no aren't they called canada goose
sure what
do you know what i'm talking about
can you bring one and like put it in the
mix i don't think it's legal because
they're migratory birds the thing about
ducks is there's like domestic ducks on
farms for duck eggs duck eggs are crazy
you have duck eggs no i don't we had
four and more protein yeah bigger fox
really hard all of them all of them were
they out in the open like yeah
bam gone
i think we got a couple eggs out of them
all right doug ripley says great guests
this week all looking out for we the
people zoo bee helps people think for
themselves whitaker made meaningful
meaningful moves as acting ag ned
provides much-needed grassroot vision
and lauren putting up fearless exposes
her latest is is her best yet
cheers thank you there you go
it was worth it nothing bad to say about
tim he's the only one that didn't f with
anyone yeah i don't know people were
people were saying that they were like
lauren put out this video of like the
truth
and then they're like she actually said
some nice things about you
yeah you were like i i no there were
there were a few really good people but
of the people that like got massive
platforms which you have you've built up
something big i never saw you once screw
anyone over and we were hanging out you
know way back in the day 2016 going to
riots in france you remember all that um
yeah and you always just were a damn
hard worker not to simp or anything i'm
sure you know you know the most brutal
thing ever is like
we do so we we try to do so well by
everybody who works at tim cast and then
the people who just knife us in the back
it's really disheartening and i can
certainly understand why bill gates is
just like there's too many people and
why people don't start companies it's
it's absolutely
getting money involved with
relationships is it totally other
dynamic dude people are evil you learn
some you you you but but i'm not i'm not
saying there's fallen nature
so i'll tell you this the as the story
goes man you hear these stories people
what people win in the lottery and then
all of a sudden
their families get torn apart it's crazy
stuff but i tell you this running a
successful business you'll be surprised
who is who in your life is truly a
friend and who isn't when you come into
success
all of a sudden people you thought you
knew your whole life are doing
everything in their power to destroy you
for no reason there are people that i've
known since i was a teenager that
immediately took to the internet and
started trying to hit up every
journalist people i was my some of my
best friends and then i'm just like i'm
hitting them up i'm like bro is did i do
something and they're like f you and i'm
like what though there's no more
disgusting emotion than jealousy in
humans yeah it's a really dark emotion
and then i learned that there are people
that i didn't like all that much that
are like well you know what man good for
you dude i get it you deserve it and i'm
like what that guy's being nice to me
man i tell you
you learned some you learned some
lessons man so lauren your documentary
that he's talking about what was it it's
called what
the whole truth it's a video just about
my time in politics all my experiences
it's three hours long i'm shocked people
even watched it but it's approaching
half a million views so it's uh yeah it
was i saw a couple two hours of it so
far you watched two hours yeah outside
while i was doing something i didn't
think people were capable of watching
videos that long so i didn't think i'd
like to see into the history of your
psychology of your experience because
i've been watching you from afar until
you came on the show i was an idiot
i came from a similar background like a
kind of an insulated family life where
their parents were really nice and like
i still have that like you know optimist
very naive view of the world you can
it's hard but you can hold on to the
optimism you just have to get a lot
smarter and realize you're not playing
with people that are playing with the
same set of rules you are sort of
yeah yeah
it's brutal man
it is brutal stuff especially when you
learn about the business things like
restrictions and uh you wonder why does
businesses do things that suck and then
you're like oh they're legally required
to that's the crazy thing
all right let's read some more here we
got uh
cromiels cromulus says just became a
member today and decided to watch the
previous after show with matt whitaker
what the frick ps that was very funny
yeah yeah that member show last night
was particularly spicy
and i was like am i going to get in
trouble
we won't we won't repeat it but maybe
maybe we'll mention on the next step no
you can watch that one i don't know i'm
just i'm just i'm really tired of so
much of the of the bs and the lies and
the manipulation from the media so uh
you know we kind of just got a little
spicy as it is what it is
all right
club rico tv says
uh trump will be blamed and demonized
for what has come coming
and he says some stuff that we can't
read on youtube but he says this is the
damn strategy trump and musk will be
blamed
but you know i i hear what you're saying
my friend i don't think that's a
revelation though to be honest i think
everyone expects trump to take the fall
for everything if trump wins the media
will just claim anything and everything
that is his fault they've even tried
doing it with some of the biden's
decisions they deal with i mean they've
done this is not just trump they've done
this with bush they've done it
throughout
however many republican presidents
are saying they're getting prepared to
do it to biden too that they're turning
around and there's some new york times
writer that just said brett stevens said
he should he should announce he's not
running for reelection now that's it yup
all right clef the misfit says tim the
president and vp candidates not being
able to be from the same state is not a
relic it's part of the 12th amendment to
the constitution also trump is a
liability in every way desantis 2024.
i hear you man on that i do i do the
thing is like i like that trump said
he's going to fire everybody and so i'm
kind of like trump desantis then
desantis desantis yeah that's but i do
knowing what trump is discussing in his
plans i think day one would be he'll
wage war on the administrative state
i think it has to happen you've got to
devolve it you've got to fire there's
hundred thousand non-essential federal
employees
they won't like a couple hundred
thousand over four years i want to avoid
what happened to the bath party in iraq
because they like basically fired the
entire bath party and then they became
uh isis or the taliban or something
there's two million there's roughly two
million federal employees
you've got there's 800 000 that have
been
deemed non-essential
you're not talking about firing all 2
million you're talking about the 800 000
non-essentials hundreds of thousands of
them should be
fired and their roles removed from the
federal agreed rules three some more we
got county says add hydro and aquaponics
to your grow back in rural philippines
building my grow
chicken tilapia vegetables plus rice and
mangoes on five acres more than we can
eat basic mechanic skills plus solar
starlink plus catholic equals win i like
the you throw in the catholic thing
there um i'm sure for a lot of people
there's a discipline in that but um i
like the aquaponics and hydroponics
stuff too that's really really cool and
then you can do
we've got a pond over at freedom stand
we'll throw some fish in there and we're
gonna we're gonna maintain it and get it
cleaned up and everything can you eat
frogs
you can if you're french
broccoli you have to be french why is it
cultural appropriation yeah that's the
rule toads frogs we got their legs for
sure
there's a lot of muscle in their legs
i've not had a frog before i've had
escargot ascargo is amazing it is yeah
wrapped in bacon oh man and in butter
garlic oil and you dip it you take it
out i love it it's delicious just like
seafood i've never done frog legs though
me neither i i don't really have a
desire to do frog questions i'm not
interested yeah all right cyridin says
corporate tax is just a way to tax the
poor it doesn't hurt the corporation
they just raise their prices
yeah yeah the idea though is
to stop companies from jumping ship
but uh someone else made it made a good
point let me see if we just had this one
i think i lost the super chat where is
it
somebody mentioned something about taxes
here we go waffle sensei says if you
implemented a global corporate tax in
fact it would not be global it would be
attacks amongst the allies then china
would lower their taxes and every
corporation would flock there
yeah
yeah
tavnazi and says lauren i watched your
recent video and i respect your resolve
having gone through all that very
disappointed to learn these things about
people i respected particularly milo
yeah a lot of background information you
haven't watched it yet no time i guess
so but um you know i talk about the
white privilege grant being stolen all
that hundred thousand somewhat dollars
um did he really steal it yeah yeah it
never went to anyone so there was like
lots of good working-class people's
money that was just went squandered by a
lot of people in this movement
unfortunately of course i believe people
have redemption and can change and
everything but there has to be some
demonstrable display of that right well
we when when people sign up at
timcast.com to be members and fund this
business i take out 96 foot tall
billboards of my rooster
full disclosure that money is not wasted
that goes to important work the craziest
thing was when i tweeted that out i got
a thousand retweets and people were like
okay that's it i'm subscribing i was
like that was the one that did it for
you like we'll keep doing that so full
disclosure i mean i mean this literally
legitimately i contacted our ad agency
and said i want to run a times square
billboard that says twitter is
protecting pedophiles and they were like
okay just send it to us and we'll see if
they approve it and i was like for real
and they're like
here's how much it costs and i was like
all right
and that phrase was rejected
the uh the
billboard the people the landlord or
whatever they were like no and then i
said tell me why so we can craft the ad
and i'm thinking maybe it'll say twitter
is protecting groomers something like
that and uh they may approve that but
we're doing it like this is
this is what it's all about you know
it's remarkable to me that we have this
business we're successful we're growing
we obviously have our standard marketing
but we're here to make an impact and do
things and hold people to account so
when twitter is actively engaging in bad
behavior and harming us i'm like well
let's make a statement and show them
that we're willing to stand up and push
back on this on this trash
where is anyone else you know the crazy
thing is
we are not the the most successful or
wealthiest people in fact car
dealerships make more money than us that
surprise to learn that was true but car
dealerships make a lot of money uh in
services and i'm like where is any one
person just to be like yeah i'll i'll we
see it sometimes but you've got all
these ultra wealthy individuals
why don't they just have a good time of
it and just be like okay we're gonna
we're gonna
get 10 billboards across this city that
just say this thing you know and just
call out people we are going to hire a
bunch of you know people to put on a
performance in the city and and generate
press and attention i just wonder why
everything's so boring and routine why
is it every billboard's always some ad
for just some you know aspirin why is it
time square is like the new clothes and
the new tv show i'm like where is the
giant rooster
where is the calling out twitter for bad
behavior where is anything to just shake
things up yeah well we're gonna do that
for sure
let's read some more super chats
all right
martin campbell says finally caught you
guys live y'all are building something
great keep it going i really do
appreciate it not only do we have a
billboard a 96-foot tall billboard of
the rooster but their mirrored billboard
so on the other side is the animated
version of roberto screaming into the
sky and then the anime version
teleporting because it's funny
because you can
because we can
but i think it's funny i think we need
irreverence we need
we need i mean everything's so stagnant
and boring and cultural when the system
is a joke you have to laugh at it that's
laughing loud and seen destination
thailand says you really need to get
lauren southern adrian curry and amanda
milius on the show at the same time that
is our recipe for crazy conversation i
love that i'd love to talk to amanda
milius in particular we've got some
ideas to discuss amanda call me well
that'd be great yeah absolutely amanda
come back on the show
adrienne however doesn't like to leave
the mountain but she hangs out in the
chat and she is a standing invite always
to come back and hang out because we're
big fans sick so oh no yeah i felt
really bad because she doesn't like to
leave her mountain and we also got or
she got sick in the airport i'm so sorry
please forgive me it's good for your
immune system adrian yeah true true
saint miles says here's a super chat to
get lauren a special glass to be kept on
the set when she comes on tim cast irl
engraved no listen i am sticking to my
working class culture initial paperclip
we are going to get a mock
high quality paper cup
so it looks like a paper cup but it's
also super elitist and expensive
all right
i can do that i can do that all right
and great
[Laughter]
porcelain or some other can you do
porcelain is that is it
ridiculous a porcelain cup that'd be
great yeah laser engraved yeah southern
zone what's like what about a gold a
gold chalice well now we're talking
that'll be nice in your hand it'll feel
warm
conductor of heat you know
if the magician says when trump said
lock her up it was for specific crimes
her illegal servers and destroying
evidence when subpoenaed it wasn't
weaponization of law it was enforcing
laws political class was above agreed
seriously oh yeah but while you're i
don't know not while you're
not during the debate i mean the first
time first time i've ever seen it during
a debate
threatening that you're going to arrest
your your opponent
perhaps
all right let's say it's just equal
application of the law
michelle j says lauren you and malice
were joking back and forth about your
license last time i made assumptions and
i legit told my husband you're a
gorgeous trans
oh am i a man that's for me to know and
the canadian government to decide
minnie strange cork says tim pick a
random member to send the empty pappy
bottles to love you lauren yeah we
actually have a whole bunch of peppy
bottles because we don't you know we
keep them so we could also you know we
have a bunch of confederate money i went
to i went to a collector's shop
and confederate money was worthless up
until recently because there's tons of
it everywhere in like huge crates it's
just
paper yeah but
as it gets older and older and older
people are starting to choose to collect
it so now it's actually becoming more
and more valuable i went to a shop and i
bought a bunch
what we're thinking of doing is we're
trying to figure out a way to do a
giveaway for the new season of tales for
the inverted world ghost of the civil
war where
we do something where certain members
will get
you'll be like we'll enter a contest
when you sign up and you will and
certain people will get mailed
literal confederate money as like a
prize and like a special thank you for
being a member we're trying to figure
out how to do that we haven't set it up
yet but that's an idea that we may
actually uh do very soon
catoth swiss says we miss mary the
friendly ghost mary is not here tonight
lauren southern is instead who is mary
the friendly ghost she's the co-host of
pop culture crisis and she just has
bleach
hair and she's pale so they call her
oh okay yeah i saw a bunch of people in
the chat they're like bring back ghost
girl
get rid of this stupid canadian we want
ghost girl i'm like all right sorry i'll
come back with bleach air chill
edward lenovo says hey tim and lauren
there's a youtuber called tick history
he's done several videos about the
history of socialism fascism nazism etc
using actual book sources references you
can look up yourself very detailed one
is five hours long about hitler should
talk with him actually having sources no
sorry we don't yeah we we don't uh
amplify anyone like that
not in the media anyways tim cast maybe
jimmy rodriguez says tim won't you
please cover the proposal by schumer in
the new ndaa it looks like gag order
subversion of whistleblower protection
think lawsuits versus the dod we'll take
a look into that i'm not i haven't heard
uh
so much about it
all right big fat cloud 45 says hey tim
i listen to the to the show late truck
driver problems lol maybe idea you
should watch iron sky and iron sky 2. it
shows a lot of today's ideas by people
very funny love y'all
um i think i've seen iron sky that's the
one where the nazis are on the moon
is that what that is i haven't seen it i
haven't seen it i don't know but there's
a sequel
iron sky the coming race
iron sky the coming race is it what is
it is it science fiction comedy film
yeah the nazis on the moon or something
okay is that what it is
i think i watched it i think i watched
part two was part two where hitler
becomes black
i am not exaggerating uh i don't know
but yeah it has to do with nazis you're
probably or no no no not hitler himself
a nazi guy because hitler is dead i'm
pretty sure in the movie yeah the secret
military base on the moon they want to
take over the earth but is part two
where they not see the nazis
they make oh no no no they make a black
guy a nazi that's what happens they
kidnap a black guy and they make him
white it's called becoming race so yeah
it's probably something through the race
is that what it is i don't know
happens to the best of those i haven't
seen
this i haven't seen this iron sky
ridiculous movie but you know what is
what it is it's got it looks like star
wars when you look at the
so many posters look like star wars
all right let's grab some super chats
patriot says looking at those hiking
ladies you could say see honey you can
do things and still keep up with your
housework
right that's my point carrying the
kitchen sink was actually reinforcing
the stereotype just hiking is what
opposes the stereotype i guess
or they could have been joking gotta
keep fit for their husbands
yeah actually
that would be a perfect gag about a
woman training to be a better housewife
so she like straps a kitchen sink on her
back and like sing bowling hands right
yeah dishes like
right pick it up that would be the joke
knitting as she yeah whatever
deadfoot says in our local dnd campaign
there was a potion thrower that was
outside of our range i was all out of
spell slots so i used mage hand to catch
the po potions to pocket the dm allowed
it good call in y'all's eyes loved the
show did he make you roll a uh dc check
on that because those potions are flying
man
you just have great reflexes i heard you
guys call that dexterity magic the
gathering with uh marjorie taylor green
have you guys ever
secret oh did you yes sorry i'm not good
have you guys ever played dungeons and
dragons on the show nope you should on
the show we actually were working on a
dungeon and dragon's show itself but we
just not enough dungeons and dragons
players to be honest everyone's still
pretty new to the game so i played
pathfinders growing up so i could train
three point three i was saying i think
we should do the the the democrat war
games you know how they did that fake d
they did their own version in 2020
yeah it was it was d they played d and d
but it was the election and they're like
rolling die to see like all right i'm
gonna try and i'm going to run an ad to
convince more voters and like roll down
like ah the ad failed you know
initiative yeah role initiative she
jumps over the desk
[Laughter]
i think i think it was probably more
boring than that it was like i'm going
to go to iowa and try and caucus better
i failed you succeed yeah yeah
you enjoy your eggs
roll up roll die
do you know what d is
ned
dungeons and dragons yeah yeah have you
played no i was like wait dude no that
is like you losers um
i've never played did you get into magic
no
is that for losers
no it's not i was okay i was raised in a
very conservative home and we didn't do
that you got a buddy that he went to
church camp and when he came back he was
like it's demonic and he burned all his
dnd books i wasn't allowed to play
pokemon growing up because my parents
were like you're summoning demons
yeah we didn't do that
we just never did it yeah it's great
well it's more about the community and
having fun and creating a story with
friends like acting all right we got
uh sean l flip says
tim cast would you have eric july on
paypal is screwing people who paid for
his new comic book uh we would have him
on we've had him on before we'll
absolutely have him on again let's have
him on we can talk about that i
immediately extended an invite to him
haven't heard back from him yet i want
everyone to understand that at
timcast.com we no longer use paypal we
use parallel economy co-founded by dan
bongino partly owned by rumble and his
censorship resistance so when you
remember not only are you supporting
alternate economic systems challenging
big tech in silicon valley you're
supporting us you're helping us do more
of the work that we do and you're
helping build up this market
we got to we got we got to win this
culture war in multiple ways one on the
policy front that's that's short term
you got to get it done now judges was
actually really smart on the on the part
of the republicans there's got to be
culture and there's got to be economics
and so we're trying to get everything
we're making a bunch of shows but we're
also making sure our infrastructure is
supporting alternate economic systems so
we use rumble infrastructure we use
parallel economy for payment processing
and the website itself is another a form
of this so if you really want to support
us head over to timcast.com become a
member we're gonna have a members only
show coming up in about an hour or so
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show you can follow us
at timcast irl you can follow me
personally at timcast ned you want to
shout anything out
uh if you're interested in more follow
me on twitter i have a lot of fun on
twitter good twitter yeah ned ryan and
it's r-y-u-n you got a book i've got
books adversary is my most recent one
it's battle of uh boston and bunker
hills last ten months before the battle
of bunker hills kind of fascinating of
of all the different dynamics between
the colonists and and the british empire
uh also restoring our republics another
book i've got you can find them on
amazon and americanmajority.org that's
my website right on
you can find me on twitter at lauren
underscore southern youtube or you can
watch my latest the whole truth video if
you've got three hours and sites like
odyssey
yeah just my name
we've got lauren here for the rest of
the week
i'm going to be hanging out apparently
i'm doing skits i have no idea what a
surprise it's a surprise i'm a surprise
actress now nice work yeah follow me ian
crossland.net and on social media ian
crossland and i want to give a special
shout out to layla and serena big fans
of chicken city you guys rock you love
chicken ian i love them too
and i saw your drawings and they're
fantastic thank you so much for being
fans and watching the show and you're
gonna do great things i can feel it see
you later and this is very important to
me i wanted to mention it before i leave
it turns out the typical hiking backpack
is about 30 pounds and a metal sink is
between 25 and 50. so either they were
building a little muscle or it's
actually less than the typical hike
should have been porcelain yeah exactly
either way not a huge win for them not
exactly sticking it to the patriarchy i
think they had backpacks too oh i don't
know yeah i was looking at it i was like
i can't see them so i don't know good
for them if they were carrying extra
weight anyway after that aside you guys
may follow me on twitterandminds.com
as well as sarah patrick stop me we will
see you all over at timcast.com thanks
for hanging out bye guys
you